just they just short they just small
talking
alright this live now yeah everybody out
there it's Saturday night yeah we've got
our liquor yeah already we'll probably
have to like stop at some blending to go
get some more breaks check on the kitty
and stuff like that cuz like I said
we're doing three cases on this show so
hopefully we'll see how long it ends up
being like I said originally when I did
the notes I had four cases and I ended
up having to take him out but the thing
about this like because several of these
cases had been requested and finally I
was like okay I'm just gonna do like a
big show about you know essentially sex
slave kidnappings and it turns out that
there are so many of these cases like so
many high-profile ones with like
fascinating details it was really hard
for me to like sort out which ones I
wanted to do and which ones I wanted to
leave out so I think eventually we're
gonna have to do at least a volume two
on this because there are at least like
three or four other cases that I wanted
to see you and that I knew that we were
gonna have time for yeah so on this one
I'm gonna cover the Ariel Castro case
because you know we've been wanting to
do that one for a long time good we just
had 12 show up yeah people are starting
to pile in put the lotion in the basket
puts the lotion here
Jamie fish Jenni fresh as in mango
badgers here I don't know if you guys
saw but we were talking about that girl
and I put the name on that last video
name was Yulia Nova yeah I don't know
Yulia Nova she supernatural supernatural
yeah supernatural boobs if you don't
know we're talking about go watch our
live with you you're right it was a boob
centric show that's right yeah and I got
a young woman from the late 90s named
Julia Nova
I think from Ukraine or Russia or
something and she probably weighed maybe
about a hundred and 510 pounds and 30 of
it was boo yeah she's cute though for
1819 so I said she you can find her on
YouTube yeah all the pictures old old
videos of her do not anything but Julia
Tammy says who took a nap did you take a
nap I tried but I couldn't
I didn't yeah I couldn't I was like I
was rereading and reread cuz you know
obsessive I get I was like reading and
rereading all my notes for this and
watching last minute documentaries and
interviews and stuff so I had like
interesting information Samuel Grimes
golfing in seven hours times be sleeping
this is dedication to the channel thank
you very much and now you're gonna be
like out there on the links and you're
gonna be all [ __ ] yeah that's alright
I'm kinda sleepy too cuz like I said on
the on the yummy review a little Pookie
woke us up at what was it zombie Leia
we're up to 17 got 17 in here they're
all starting to come in everybody's
coming in yeah alright people showing up
yeah you guys would kill on watch
parties on Twitch we should probably do
that one in a while
yeah yeah we could do I don't know we
could do like all kinda we could do
horror movies we could look into [ __ ]
yeah cuz like I said it's I know we we
kind of put off live streaming for a
long time but it's honestly it's like
it's kind of more fun than doing the the
recording like I said it's easier
because I don't have as much editing to
do on the back end but it's also like
you said I have less fear of like just
like sitting here with nothing to say
because you know there's always people
asking questions and interacting and
stuff and I actually do kind of like
this in danza Kresnik do some shitty
movie riffs I just can't do it on top of
my head I'm not drunk yet dance yeah
Dennis will probably make an appearance
let's eat
yeah this definitely seems like a topic
that Dennis will probably have
insight in sale yeah which in case you
didn't see the title card we're talking
about sex slave kidnappings yeah we're
doing the Ariel Castro case the Fritzl
case which is one of the most [ __ ] up
things ever and the case of Elizabeth
Smart yeah and like I said I was I was
saying earlier that there were so many
cases of this that had like similar
details that I could that it was really
hard for me to decide like which ones to
do and we're probably just gonna have to
do like a second volume at some point so
I can cover some other cases that are
because I was gonna do Colleen stand on
this one to you but then I was like man
I'm just not gonna have to do all these
I'm gonna have to do volume two but yeah
okay we're doing yeah okay so all right
so we're gonna start out I just got a
couple of shout outs remember how I said
I was doing like second editions of a
lot of my fiction and stuff like that
well I finally finished the print and
ebook second edition of my book hopeful
monsters the original came out in 2009
but I just recently did kind of a revamp
of it I added like four or five new
stories you know I added new photos I
did a new cover and all this other stuff
I also did an audiobook version which
I've uploaded the audio files but it's
still going through you know the quality
control or whatever so it'll probably be
like a couple weeks unless there's a
[ __ ] but the the new version of the
print and the e-book is already up there
so if you want to check that out that
would be really cool and I'll let you
guys know when the audiobook is
available also also we have two new
patrons this week bunny who I think I
shat it out on one of our matinee shows
and Bunyip or Bunge if there's a J but I
know how sometimes so and I actually
Korean they're actually Australian
Australian yeah they were said like they
were saying hello from Australia they
just came on like last night I think
like right before I close down the
office and what ii went to watch a
Gordon Ramsay for the evening
yeah so thank you very much you guys to
kind of big heavy hitters so that's
really cool man getting a lot of patrons
getting know which is like I said we
just went over nine thousand subscribers
on the YouTube channel so it's very
exciting very exciting just started with
the live streaming you know how we do
yeah Tom's not yet drunk enough to
channel dentist though probably not know
he started rolling yet yeah we only just
we only just generally drinking oh yeah
you've made a pretty impressive Denton
now that wasn't a big drink oh okay I
thought it was like all the way to the
top no I was like holy [ __ ] did you like
have a beer
big giant man jar already I got silver
tequila and in lemonade with some lime
juice in it that sounds delicious
other than the tequila bars right I just
have my regular [ __ ] this is just sky
man man Sheila that's re not man enough
for tequila see that's a tiger okay I
don't know if you I don't know if you
like that as much of I involved yeah
exactly
[Laughter]
but yeah
kind of sleepy hmm I am too like I said
yeah we talked about this on the yummy
review earlier today but it's like a
little Pookie woke us up at 6:00 in the
morning cuz she was very excited that
she had well she hadn't yet killed it
but she had disabled a big huge
cockroach yeah that was got in the room
palmetto bugs about that over yeah like
I said so she had to like wake us up and
be like look look I got the monster I
say a few guys so you know what I mean
so I tried to go back to sleep but I
couldn't say yeah I'm really really
sleepy
so it's like probably like by the time
that I get like enough alcohol in me
I'll just be completely incoherent but I
did ask like before we started recording
I'm like you do know some [ __ ] about
this case right so in case I totally
spaced out like you'll be able to kind
of like bingo cuz I remember you being
you read a lot about the Ariel Castro
case because you were kind of one of the
ones that once it's they want to do it
you know what I mean
and I remember when it happened yeah it
wasn't that long ago 2013 yeah I mean we
were living here then weren't we yeah
yeah I think yeah yeah it wasn't that
long ago because I remember all that
shouldn't happen and I remember I
remember all the stuff with Charles
Ramsey and yeah dead giveaway he read a
book yeah a dead giveaway hey that song
dead giveaway this I still can't like
now every time cuz I watched a bunch of
documentaries and news footage and stuff
like that about this
Enda like to refresh my memory and it's
like I can't hear him talking without
hearing that song that they made out of
his interview it did give a win I was
like wow it was really good at riding
everything I was like and it's like
really catchy so now every time I hear
him talking looks like all I can hear is
that song I just thought it was very
funny that he called the book dead
giveaway I've heard that he's not I mean
he seems like a cool person but it's
like I guess he's got like some criminal
history and so he's created yeah some
[ __ ] like that so I guess he's not like
a fantastic person but he's like a good
person because he like didn't save that
girl yeah although the thing is it's
like there was another neighbor that
came over there too and it's like that
guy never gets any attention yeah I'm
hella cordero or whatever it was like
the first one over there but yeah so he
peed help too but far as I know he
didn't get free McDonald's like I think
he got a lifetime or something like that
yeah because he kept saying that he was
just every day we go get mcdonalds yeah
since they made a movie I get McDonald's
yeah he was said they were just like hey
thanks man it's like you know big hero
and he's like plugging how much he loves
McDonald's I thought that was really
funny yeah so we're gonna talk about
that case first the Ariel Castro case
now this was an this kind of [ __ ] I mean
okay we do like a lot of true crime on
here and it's bad enough when somebody
gets like kidnapped and murdered
obviously that's terrible but in a way
people that get kidnapped and then like
put in like a basement or like locked in
someone's house kept it and then they're
in there for like 10 years or like in
the Fritzl case she was there for 24
years forensics like it's like I can't
even imagine what that must be like and
what their day-to-day life must have
been like I mean that's just like a
horrifying thing to think about and the
fact that they can come out the other
end because I was watching just like a
couple hours ago I was just watching
like interviews with you know Amanda
Berry and Michelle Knight and Gina
DeJesus and they just seemed like
completely normal you miss they were in
for like ten eleven years they were
trapped in this crazy person's house
he's beaten um and stuff
beating them raping them like [ __ ]
it's like Jesus Christ how do you even
use punching the babies out of them yeah
how do you even like recover from
something like that like the fact that
they can just come out and be normal
people again that just like blows my
[ __ ] mind you know what I mean yeah
they were saying we eat ribs with this
dude and we didn't have like there was
we in that house but do you yeah that's
exactly normal riding sport bikes having
[ __ ] barbecues wait outside think I
was in a band yeah everybody knew the
guy he drove a school bus yeah
it's [ __ ] crazy yeah it's [ __ ]
crazy I mean because you would never
think that about your news wall you know
it's like in this neighborhood like our
neighbors gonna have people in the
basement we would never have I don't
know what the [ __ ] they're doing over
there you know I mean the the creepy we
know that yeah that's what I mean there
is no way of knowing it's like and it's
kind of easy to say and you'll see this
like in a lot of the and all the cases
we're gonna talk about most of our
neighbors I've never seen yeah cuz a lot
of them don't usually as never seen you
know you don't see him it's like every
now and then I'll see them like you know
coming out like and get in the car and
go in somewhere like in the morning or
something but it's like you don't
usually see him like or out mowing the
lawn or whatever but you'll see that in
like I feel like once that like Stace
once the girls were rescued you know
it's very easy to look back now that
everybody knows that they were in there
the whole time to go back and go why
didn't anybody XYZ what anybody noticed
why didn't anybody hear anything wanted
to do anything but the thing about it is
that would that occur to you like I said
if I was walking in my back unless for
an example if I was walking around in my
backyard and heard somebody yelling from
next door you know what I mean or like
heard banging or something like that I
wouldn't necessarily think anything of
it I would just think oh there's Saudis
playing or it's their kid or something
like that I think that's what most
people would think so it's easy to kind
of look back you know hindsight's 20/20
and say somebody should have noticed you
know particularly the way Ariel Castro
was it's like oh people weren't allowed
like he wouldn't let anybody his house
and like there was you know wood or some
of the windows and stuff like that but a
lot of the houses and then
were kind of junky or kind of crappy and
he acted pretty normal like other than
the not letting people come in his house
thing set one of the neighbors said they
said that they saw a naked girl come
running out on her here we got everybody
now and that was it
or the damn leash around her neck see
now that and then he went out there and
got her that's a detail of it but now
that should have been a red flag but
it's weird because that's a detail that
I hear it every now and then like again
my doubts yeah but then in some accounts
I don't yeah so it's like I don't know
if that was like a detail that was added
later or was embellished the explanation
I heard was that the people just thought
it was some kind of consensual [ __ ]
Kiki [ __ ] going on yeah and like I said
I guess that something that you would
think that everybody's just like oh
that's how that is going on in the
family there and you wouldn't
necessarily think anything about it I do
feel like people I mean I do feel like
if people knew you're in distress they
would most people would try to help you
but I think also people are like man
that's their business and I'm gonna stay
out of it too
because you don't want to like get all
up in people's faces in they're just
like hey this is just a thing that we do
you know what I mean you don't want to
interfere with it so it's like I can I
can understand like how that happens now
in the case of the Fritzl case which
we'll probably talk about second that
one I I don't know I feel like a lot of
people [ __ ] on the guy's wife for not
knowing what was going on or so like
that and I can kind of see that she live
in the house though yes she did
Ariel Castro's why no I said the frontal
case oh okay yeah yeah sure yeah he
lived alone yeah
you know before like he asserted that
his wife had left him understandably
because he beat the [ __ ] out of her as
well which we will get into so all right
so the Ariel Castro case like I said
this happen in Cleveland Ohio
this was the kidnapping of three girls
in separate incidents between 2002 and
2004 and these girls were kept in this
[ __ ] [ __ ] house for you know
between 10 11 12 years until they
finally
in 2013 one of the girls Amanda berry
gave birth to a daughter while she was
imprisoned the daughter Jocelyn was six
years old when the girls finally escaped
one of the other girls the first girl
that was kidnapped Michelle night
she was actually a young woman she was
impregnated at least five times but he
Ariel Castro induced miscarriages in her
every single time by hitting her in the
abdomen with dumbbells or with his fists
or other things I think what ended up
happening and I feel like poor Michelle
Knight she gets kind of the short end of
the stick I feel like because she was
actually the first one taken she was 21
years old when she was taking the other
girls were younger and the thing about
her is that her parents I guess they
weren't looking for they weren't really
looking for her because the problem was
doing yeah it's just it's just kind of
like I feel like she kind of gets the
shorter of the stick like I said because
she you know the other two girls had
their family you know coming out and
like they've had posters they were on
the news all the time they were on
Montel they were on Oprah they were on
set and I feel like Michelle Knight's
parents because she was taken first they
just just because she was an adult they
just assumed that she was a runaway or
that she was a [ __ ] or something like
that because there was a thing where she
had actually on the day that she was
kidnapped she was on her way to like a
court hearing because her son had been
taken out of her custody now what I
heard allegedly the reason that he was
taken out of her custody wasn't because
of anything she did in particular but I
read that her mother's boyfriend at the
time
I guess Michelle left the kid whose name
was Joey with that guy like for like to
watch him for a few minutes while she
doing something and he hurt the kid um
so I guess CPS thought that well you
shouldn't have left him with that guy
and so it's kind of your fault too so
they took the kid out of her custody so
on the day when she was taken she was
actually going to a court hearing to
argue that she should get her son back
and the sad thing was that so when she
was kidnapped her parents just assumed
oh well she was just pissed because she
thought she wasn't get her son back and
she probably just ran away and they
didn't really look for her all that hard
yeah and it really does seem like -
because she was over 18 so what does
that do they she was only in the
missing-persons registry or whatever for
like 18 months and then they took her
off it because they just assumed so well
she just took off town and you know
there's nothing we can do about it
because she's a grown-up so I mean I saw
an interview with her I watched it today
she's changed her name and everything
like that and she seems like a lovely
human being and it's really as sad that
she I mean she didn't come out she was
actually the most physically harmed by I
mean she had the most injuries she was
in the hospital longer than the other
sale and she was fighting him more and
she was there the longest I mean she was
there like 11 years because she was
taken in 2002 and I kind of feel like
the reason that he took her was because
I mean even though she was 21 she was a
little bitty girl I mean she was only I
think she was only four foot and or
something and she was like she was just
like a tiny little person and I think
that maybe he thought that she was
younger than she was it's weird because
and another thing too I feel like there
was kind of some victim blaming and even
Ariel Castro did this himself like at
his [ __ ] trial where he would kind of
vacillate between you know oh I'm sorry
I did this I have a pornography
addiction and all the other kind of crap
but also blaming them for getting into a
car with a stranger even though he
wasn't really a stranger to them it's
like some of it like I believe Gina was
friends with his daughter and Amanda
went to school with his one of his kids
or two of his
kids they knew who he was he wasn't just
like a stranger it was like you know
they all lived on the same street or in
the same neighborhood and he drove a bus
they all kind of knew each other so he
wasn't just like a total creeper they
couldn't escape because he at first he
kept him handcuffed to some pipes
underneath they were chained chained up
yet what he did what base what the two
girls that I saw an interview with Gina
and Amanda and they said they were
locked in these two upstairs rooms and
there was like a hole in the wall that
had a chain through it and they were
attached to the same chain like through
the wall if ever so I thought they were
down in the basement chained up to some
[ __ ] pipes I think they might have
bought it later did like he got him out
of there he later moved them up to the
upstairs bedrooms but they were locked
in there and they were chained together
and they just you know they just had
buckets in there and yeah and one thing
that he would do too is that like I said
a lot of the windows were boarded up the
doors were locked like the front the
front two doors there was actually two
doors it was like a metal storm door and
limbs like a bigger door and he kept
that locked and another thing that he
would do too and this was the reason
that they were kind of like afraid to
leave sometimes even when he left was
that he would do a thing where he would
leave a door open or he believe like a
window partially open or something and
then he would just kind of go down the
street and if they tried to like yell or
if they tried to escape or something
like that he would come back or like he
was testing them so he would do that a
lot too so they just got into the habit
of every time that happened they thought
that he was [ __ ] with them and that
he was just gonna come back and beat the
[ __ ] out of them because he was just
testing them to see if they would leave
yeah you know what I mean so he had you
know kinds of mind control he did and
and but it should be noted that despite
that like as soon as Amanda Barry that
particular day noticed that not that the
big door was open now the storm door was
still closed and locked but as soon as
she knows it was opened that his car was
gone and that there was a neighbor on
the porch across the street she
immediately went there and stuck her arm
out through the door and started
screaming so it's not like she was you
know completely like institutionalized
or whatever you want to say because as
soon as she got the opportunity you know
she she started yelling and got the [ __ ]
out
they're so you know now all right so
here's what happened with Ariel Castro
so Ariel Castro was actually born in
Puerto Rico but his parents divorced
when he was pretty young and he moved to
to the United States particularly
Pennsylvania with his mom and then they
ended up moving to Cleveland where a lot
of his other relatives were now he had a
girlfriend like you know when he got
older he graduate from high school and
he had this girlfriend named grimille de
Figueroa now he his family moved in
across the street from her family so
that's how they met from what I heard um
it was kind of a case of he didn't
really care about her in particular he
was just like a woman and he just like
wanted a woman around to like abuse I
guess so it's like she was as good as
any cuz she was just like across the
street so they ended up getting married
and they I guess they lived with his
parents and they lived with her parents
cuz like I said they lived across the
street but then they got their own house
to 2:07 Seymour Avenue they moved in
here in 1992 and this was the house
where all of the girls would eventually
be imprisoned now it kind of looked like
it's gone now cuz the city tore it down
but it looked like a dump like when you
saw it in the news and everything like
that I don't know how much of a dump it
was when they bought it it had been it
had been built like in 1890 so it was
like a really old house but it was very
large and it had like a really big
basement so as soon as these two moved
in to this house moved in together
that's when relatives and stuff like
that started saying that aerial capture
started beating the [ __ ] out of his wife
he apparently broke her ribs he broke
her nose broke her arms on multiple
occasions he also hit her so hard in the
head that he caused a blood clot which
eventually caused a tumor that would
kill her several years later
so that's nice yeah so he threw her down
the stairs he did all this other kind of
[ __ ] now he did actually get arrested
for domestic violence in 1992 but the
grand jury failed to indict him so I
don't know how that was a wife-beater
yeah big time um so his wife got the
[ __ ] out in 1996 they had four kids and
she took all of them with her thankfully
now the cops actually came there and
helped her move out of the house but
then again they didn't press charges
against him um even after she left
he continued to threaten her and harass
her kidnapped the kids on a couple of
occasions she got a restraining order
but it was only in effect for a couple
of months and then it was dismissed so
this woman just really didn't seem to
get taken seriously at any point and
they actually like talk to some of Ariel
Castro's family members because he had
quite a lot of family that lived in the
area and it's kind of sad and I guess
this you know it's better now but I
guess even in this time period you know
domestic violence was just kind of
something that happened and even as
other family members knew about it and
they were just kind of like well it's
not our business
yeah I think I had a lot to do with the
fact that there was kind of like
Hispanic communities and stuff and the
income level had a lot to do with it the
policing was pretty busy I think like in
an area where there wasn't so much crime
they probably would have done something
about it
everything's on a scale yeah at Rio I
guess it just depends on what the orders
of Pryor where was this again Cleveland
Ohio yeah I remember looking at that
area it look like a high crime area I'm
not yeah I'm not sure what the crime
statistics are um I've heard Cleveland
is kind of a dump I've never been there
so if anybody is in Cleveland they can
tell me but um
somebody asked was an Elizabeth Smart in
Utah yeah that was Utah yeah that
Mormons but yeah well we'll probably do
that one
that one last yeah so like I said
Castro's wife girlfriends they ever get
married I don't even know this was
Wikipedia said girlfriend but then I
thought they got married at some point
but she ended up dying in 2012 because
of the brain tumor that he had inflicted
was with the blood clot everything like
that now so Castro worked as a school
bus driver for a long time like 22 years
that's a really long time it was for the
Cleveland metropolitan school district
now he eventually got fired for doing
[ __ ] like like he would make illegal
u-turns like with a bus full of kids he
used the bus to go grocery shopping he
left a kid on the bus like he would go
to his house for lunch or good ones and
he would leave a kid on the bus and go
hey duck down in the bus so nobody sees
you like he got a gig this obligor
yeah and like he would like leave the
bus like unlocks like on the street
while he went in his house and took a
nap and like [ __ ] like that he would do
[ __ ] like that which you know and I
think that was one incident - which
might have been the same one with the
lunch and making the kids stay on the
bus but it's like he that was kind of
considered because he was supposed to be
taking the kid home like because that's
what school bus is for but instead he's
like nah man I'm just I'm getting hangry
so I got a stop and you have to stay on
the bus you know what I mean so I can go
get something to eat so I'm not gonna
take you home yet even though that's
what I'm supposed to do
so I think it was that kind of thing so
he did eventually end up getting fired
also when he was arrested here's
something interesting that I didn't know
his house where the girls were being
kept captive was actually in foreclosure
because he had not paid real estate
taxes for three years dang so he would
have gotten caught eventually I guess
when they came to foreclose although
foreclosure does take a really really
long time so taking on longtime who
knows how long it would have had a
warning yeah he probably would have
killed him he very well may have yeah um
you know it's he would have killed him
and then gotten rid of the bodies jaren
fluke foreclosure and moved out of there
he was gonna let him live what was weird
is that he had a kid with one of them I
don't know how he's gonna
resolve that do you know do you know
what he did with that because like I
said he had a daughter with joseline
well he raped her yeah and Amanda Amanda
Barry had a daughter and what he would
do was he he was apparently super proud
of this kid he had pictures of the kid
and the phone and everything he would
even go around to his family members and
say that it was his girlfriend's kid all
right even though some of his relatives
were like man that looks just like your
sister let looks just like a relative
like they were saying they were marking
on their resemblance because it was kid
right but he was saying no no that's you
know it's my girlfriend's kid like
that's what he would tell people so he
did like say like call called the kid
like his granddaughter which she
technically was but he didn't say like
where exactly she come from which that's
really [ __ ] oh we couldn't say because
they want to meet the mom yeah I know
it's like What did he say so this is my
this is my girlfriend's daughter but
he's like where your girlfriend oh she
lives in Canada you don't know where
like it did he pull that kind of crap
right like when she's at work or
something yeah I don't know I don't
really get it but yeah so like I said
Michelle night was the first one to
disappear now she was this was August
23rd 2002 she had been over at her
cousin's house and she was going like I
said she was going to a court hearing
about the custody of her son Joey and um
she was I guess she was walking down the
street and she was offered a ride by
Ariel Castro now like I said she knew
him so I mean she didn't like know him
know him but it's like you know it was
like a friend of her friend's dad or
something like that so it wasn't like
completely weird so he said he was gonna
give her a ride you know to the court or
wherever she was going and he's like oh
ah you know he does that thing where oh
I gotta stop by the house first of all
blonde she didn't really think that much
about it but as soon as she got inside
the house he basically like [ __ ] beat
her tied her up and she was
and stuck there now as I said because
she was 21 years old when she vanished
and because there had been some issues
with you know her son being taken away
and her family miss perceiving that she
might have wanted to get away because of
that they didn't really they did kind of
look for her at first you know they put
her in the missing-persons registry they
did this any other but it really did
kind of seem like you know they weren't
really looking for her all that hard
because she was an adult and after 18
months you know in 2003 they actually
quietly took her off of the
missing-persons database because I guess
they assumed she had run off and was
living a life somewhere it should be
noted interestingly that after the three
girls were rescued Michelle Knight
changed her name and she absolutely
refused to have anything to do with her
family after that so she was not happy
about it but know more about it than we
do that's what and in a way like I'm
glad I'm you know what I mean because if
there was a reason there had to have
been a reason and if she decided she's
like I don't want this toxic [ __ ] in
my life because maybe that's what her
family was you know maybe there was like
some abuse going on I don't know but she
basically was like I don't want anymore
that [ __ ] [ __ ] in my life and she
just like said [ __ ] off and she didn't
want to see them anymore which you know
good for her and like I said she's I saw
an interview with her that was came out
a couple years ago and she seems like a
really lovely like well-adjusted person
now so evidently it seems that she made
the right decision so the next one to
disappear was Amanda berry she
disappeared on April 21st 2003 this was
the day before her 17th birthday now she
had been working she worked at Burger
King and she was supposed to get a ride
home from a friend but apparently she
called this friend and the friend did
not pick up or didn't answer so she just
said well [ __ ] it and she just started
walking home cuz it wasn't that far
at which point Ariel Castro pulls up in
the car like I said she kind of
recognized him she had seen
around town and he was in a car with
somebody that she kind of knew so it
really didn't seem all that nefarious so
she got in the car with him as well and
he took her to the house and
subsequently locked her in there now
again just like in the case of Michele
night the cops initially thought well
she's just a runaway was she upset about
something blah-dee-blah
and they kind of for about a week after
she disappeared they were coming at it
from that angle even though her parents
were insisting it's like look she
wouldn't do that it's like she was
looking forward to her birthday you know
she was work she was a normal person
it's like she wouldn't have she she had
never run away before so you know the
cops you know they are it's just though
you know how teenagers do she's ran away
blah blah blah but then a week after she
disappeared
Ariel Castro called her mother on
Amanda's cell phone and said I have
Amanda she's fine and will be coming
home in a couple of days at which point
the cops were like oh I guess she was
kidnapped duh
so you know what I mean so yeah so then
they and like I said they didn't it
feels like they didn't initially connect
her case with the Michelle Knight case
because the thing about what a man of
Bury disappeared her family were very
very vocal about coming out and I mean
they plastered her face all over
everything they you know they just like
went at it and they were just like
really trying to find her um so I feel
like Michelle kind of got lost in the in
the shuffle because they didn't connect
the two you know what I mean
they were still looking at that as a
runaway and like I said Amanda Berry's
family were a lot more I guess proactive
in looking for her and keeping her name
in the media you know so everybody would
know you know you know keeping news
about her alive now sadly there was this
guy that was kind of a false lead that
came out in 2012 this was like a year or
so before they were rescued this guy
named Robert Walford and he was in
prison and he had lived in that same
neighborhood of
Cleveland where the girls had
disappeared and he came forward to the
cops and said that he knew where Amanda
Berry's body was so they let him out of
prison like - like they didn't let him
out let him out but they let him they
said okay show us where it is he led
them to an empty lot in Cleveland and
the cops spent however long they spent
like searching around and of course she
was not there because she was still
alive he's wanted to do yeah he just
wanted to get out of prison face it was
what he wanted to do maybe he did used
to live in that neighborhood and he
thought hey here's a way I can get a day
out of jail you know or maybe he's like
I bet I know where they adopt her it
could have been that gee maybe he was
genuinely trying to hit I don't know but
I I mean I doubt it but it could it
could be I don't guess obviously she was
not dead yeah you don't get out that day
yeah and he just went yeah he just
wanted to get out and he was hoping
they'd buy him some McDonald's yeah
so he actually did get in trouble for
doing that for you know because so he
got four and a half years like added on
to a sentence for obstruction of justice
for on top oh yeah they were like yeah I
hope you enjoyed that day out it'll be
your last one for four years no I guess
not
before you did this the next girl to
disappear was Gina DeJesus now she was
only shouldn't mention Amanda Barry was
17 when she disappeared she was almost
17 Gina DeJesus was only 14 she was last
seen standing at a payphone at around
3:00 in the afternoon she was walking
home from Middle School this was on
April 2nd 2004 now she was actually very
good friends with Ariel Castro's
daughter Arlene and in fact the two of
them had been hanging out on this
particular day and Arlene was supposed
to go over to Gina's house for a
sleepover
but Arlene's mom who was you know
Ariel's ex-wife who like had gotten beat
up by him was like no you know you we
have other things to do or whatever so
we wouldn't let her have a sleepover so
they you know so Arlene goes back to her
house and Gina starts walking toward
back toward her house and that is when
Ariel picked her
like I said this was not weird she
wasn't getting into a car with a
stranger she had just been hanging out
with the dudes daughter that was like
her good they were like best friends so
she's like oh it's Arielle it's it's
Arlene's dad it's Rhine it's weird
yeah how'd that turn out see can't trust
anybody man telling you simple it was it
was a one-off well he said and I'll just
know said the chance does that happen it
to a person of very I know it is slim
but it's you know what I mean it's like
but you never the the scary thing is you
never know which one it's gonna be it's
like you might do that a hundred times
and it's fine but then like the only
takes one time for it to be fine you
know I mean it all it takes is one crazy
person but yeah so the so I kind of like
lost what my train of thought was okay
so so she gets in the car now nobody
really thought to again they they kind
of considered it as a runaway case so
they didn't issue an Amber Alert for her
because no one had seen her get taken or
nobody saw anything weird obviously it
was like middle of the afternoon and her
dad was like really kind of upset about
that because he was like look it's like
it's just odd [ __ ] it has some do at
that area and [ __ ] um somebody in the
comments section said that this area is
a shitty area oh it looks like a shitty
area kind of you know what I mean yeah
um you know it it I don't know if it was
shittier than or at the shittier now
than it was then or I don't know but has
a very overworked police force yeah and
there's a lot of troubled kids and
they're always running away and doing
stupid [ __ ] to them it's just another
one so it's just another was just
another one which is sad because it's
like you know even if in you know 85% of
cases that's what it is there's always
that 15% of cases where because if you
have a population of troubled youth like
that you're gonna get people that are
preying on that exact demographic so
most of them come don't come up dead
it's rare true and if they do come up
dead it's other other little kid
to kill them yeah I mean I don't you
mean other little kids yeah teenagers
teenagers yeah over stupid [ __ ] it's not
some kind of serial killer yeah well
that's why you hear about it when it
happens yeah yeah I mean I try to tell
myself that because it's like you know I
write about true crimes so it's like I'm
up to my eyeballs and true crime like
all the time so you really do have to
kind of step back and go as horrible as
a lot of these cases are you know
they're rare and that's why we're
interested in them and that's why we
hear about them all the time is because
it's unusual it doesn't happen every day
and I'm not saying that it couldn't
happen to any one of us tomorrow like if
we're particularly unlucky and I've
written about some really horrifying
cases where it's just somebody like
walking down the street minding their
own beeswax and somebody jumps out of
the [ __ ] bushes and like stabs and
[ __ ] but you can't live your whole life
worrying about that because it's very
very very unlikely that it's gonna
happen it could happen and I hope it
doesn't but it you know it's
statistically very unlikely I would be
more worried about getting hit by a car
or I mean or getting in a car accident
which is a lot more likely than getting
killed by just a random yes car yeah
motorcycle accidents yeah I would be a
lot more worried about that because
that's that is you know monumentally
more likely to happen than just [ __ ]
like organ failure disease yes a lot of
people yeah I mean I'm talking about
like really skim you know I'm not saying
the heart attacks and stuff like that
isn't scary but usually when people
think about like I'm talking about like
violence like [ __ ] that's like you know
violence happening to him I think it's
much more likely that you're gonna get
like and a lot of it depends on what
your zip code is where you live well
yeah obviously because obviously some
neighborhoods for much safer than others
some whole cities are collapsing like
some of these cases that we covered in
the past
remember there'd be like two or three
serial killers working in one city and
it was because you know a bunch of a
bunch of roads interstates go through
that City and then that city's caught
economies collapsing and yet population
is collapsing so it's leaving behind a
lot of low-income people and some of
them are kind of like parasites feeding
off a dad like a maggot feeding off a
dying body well a lot of times
- when you have like transient puppies
there's they're people that don't stay
there for very long and don't like that
like I said you saw that a lot like
during like the hippie era like yeah in
California because there were a lot of
people wanting to go to California
because they're like the movies and it
was warm and everything like that so you
had like a lot of young people cycling
through there that didn't necessarily
have any family or any roots in the area
and you had people following them like
preying on that like yeah there's only
preying on the prostitutes though well
they're prostitutes because the economy
[ __ ] dried up that's what I me and it
affected their families and then you
know I mean there were kids that fell to
drugs because the income was gone and in
order to get the drugs they had to
[ __ ] resort to prostitution that
whole area is [ __ ] collapsing and
they're in like an apocalyptic situation
and yeah and he never would have died
had that economy not collapses [ __ ] like
that and I kind of hate that the way I I
hate the way like serial killers that
primarily target sex workers say I mean
I feel like they don't get as much
attention unless they kill a [ __ ] ton of
them like the Green River Killer or
something like that
I feel like serial killers that killed
you know pretty young white girls like
college students or you know good girls
or you know or guys I feel like they get
a lot more because it's sad but people
like feel like a lot more sympathy for
like I said somebody that was just like
a college student or we're just going
about their day I guess cuz you can
relate to people more like that because
they're more like you I suppose but you
have to think that you know people that
are sex workers most of them didn't
wanna do that you know I mean it's not
like that was their [ __ ] career goal
when they were good it's like they ended
up in that situation you know probably
for shitty reasons the crowds reminded
me that I need to refill that drink are
you gonna rebuild it in look at that
that's just oh my god hello it is
already and it's only 45 minutes so
that's that's good for that's good for
conversation though waken yeah is it you
gonna go get one yeah yeah no one cares
about the less dead people of color and
sex workers it's true and it's like it's
really really sad and I feel like that's
kind of I kind of got a little bit of
that vibe like talking about that
thinking about the Ariel Castro case and
wash
a lot of the documentaries about it is
that Amanda berry and Gina DeJesus got a
lot more attention than Michelle Knight
did you know and some of that might be
attributable to you know the latter two
girls parents being more involved in
their lives being more worried about
them I guess I'm like having more
resources at hand to like you know go
talk to the media like put up more
posters and things things like that
whereas Michelle Knight's family seemed
a little more like laissez-faire
about where she went to so she just kind
of got shuffled on and the fact I mean
when they found all four all all the
girls all three girls it's like no one
even remembered like everybody knew who
Amanda Berry was everybody knew who Gina
DeJesus was because they'd been all over
the news but then they were kind of like
oh and there's this other girl in here
named Michelle Knight and nobody
remembered that she had been a missing
person or anything like that because
they just assumed that she had been a
runaway and that kind of bummed me out
um but like I said I you know I saw a
recent interview with her and she seems
like I mean a really a wonderful person
and she really seems to have like gotten
her [ __ ] together and I just feel bad
that like she seemed to kind of get you
know and some of it might have been on
her to you because I think she didn't
really want to talk to the press at
first like the other two kind of were
more willing to come out and talk to the
media and stuff and she took a little
while longer so you know but I don't
know so it does kind of bother me that
when you know serial killers that just
go after prostitutes they tend to get I
mean look at something like the Long
Island Long Island serial killer and you
know people like that that target like
Craigslist escorts and whatnot I feel
like there is definitely an element of
like victim blaming in there it's like
well you shouldn't have been doing that
and you shouldn't be a sex worker you
shouldn't be and s4 on Craigslist and
that's what you get and I do feel like
there's a little bit of that just a
little bit you know I wouldn't say much
because they all get the same arrests of
credits the police and the fun yeah
prosecutors for the gifts incra
credits for the convictions what it is
this they're they're harder to catch
they're harder to catch because there's
no because they see so many guys a day
yeah and they're yeah there's no person
connection between I mean him like I
said even if the victims aren't sex
workers it's always harder to catch a
serial killer that targets that are not
related look at it from the tone of a
connection you got to look at it from
the point of view of the investigator
they come at it may say this prostitute
got killed he goes oh [ __ ] because he
already knows it's a tough case yeah
because they're seeing maybe yeah I want
to do it'd be any one of them and
there's no records right yes and then
you go here's another one news oh [ __ ]
and then here's another one oh [ __ ]
so he knows a serial killer there's no
way of track and who it is is seeing
these but I mean see that's why in
another way I think that legalizing it
would make it so much safer it would
make it so much easier because then
there'd be records there'd be you
wouldn't have like this whole
underground economy you know where if
something terrible happens to you you
would have recourse you know you're not
doing anything illegal yourself so you
can actually go to the cops and go hey
this guy beat me up for this guy try to
kill me and they can do something about
it
it's another conversation I mean I
believe that they ought to legalize that
yeah but you have to look at the places
where it's legal in the United States
how it's run brothels you usually run as
prisons the girls have to stay there
they can't leave it's kind of inhuman
yeah obviously that's a Nicole we know
why they do that they do it because they
usually have drug problems yeah
so the brothels don't want them leaving
and [ __ ] not coming back right or
leaving and getting in trouble because
they're [ __ ] drug problems they don't
show back up for work yeah so they kinda
like have them in protective custody
partially yeah they're all drug addicts
around here no they shouldn't be yeah
but that's that's who usually falls into
that work you know or now if they're not
into it previously they'll get into it
after yeah now here's another thing oh I
wanted to say thank you to DJ maniac Oh
Long Island serial killer we did a show
about that like Oh quite a while ago
there's actually a movie I think it's on
Netflix we reviewed the movie as well I
think it's called Lost Girls and it's
kind of like a personalization at least
of one of those gonna say something
about legalized prostitution
yeah I think it should be legal okay and
regulated yeah just like any is dead I'm
gonna maritime American right and I
understand American mentality what they
would do is they would corporate eyes it
yeah and then it would start opening up
franchises yeah like and anyway yeah and
then they would start recruiting girls
from a young age and to make it a damn
industry and then the next thing you
know you know and I've never had any
children I'm not a father but Here I am
as a father of [ __ ] daughters you
know I mean and they're being enticed by
a eighty or ninety thousand dollar a
year career as a [ __ ] corporate
prostitute in a [ __ ] chain of [ __ ]
brothels and then you got to ask
yourself what kind of society is this
where you start making women of [ __ ]
physical commodity it's just you know I
mean its citizens are those happy Selina
because it's like if you keep it illegal
you're right then it gets then its
lightness very danger and if you
legalize it in an American sense the
America corporate eyes it yeah [ __ ]
meek that's what I mean it's like better
not neither of those options are good
but I think I would err on the side of
like them not getting beat up and
murdered I don't know what do you guys
think you guys agree with me with them
with the American the [ __ ] out on that
[ __ ] put it on roids
and damn make damn yes it would be like
the AMC theater chain well I mean just
look at we do have you know legalized
brothels in parts of Nevada yes but like
I said they're kind of like prisons yeah
where they're not allowed out it's weird
I'm all for like if somebody wants to do
that that is completely their
prerogative um you know I wouldn't do it
it doesn't sound like a good time but I
understand that there are people that
would choose to do that and I don't have
a problem with that and I don't know but
like you said I I think having it be
illegal is just way more dangerous for
the women it probably wouldn't be great
if it was legal either but I think it
would be better than it being illegal
and them not having any recourse you
know like I said when they get beat up
or raped or murdered um you know I feel
like it would be much better because
then you could get
you know you'd have resources you'd have
records you know like who their clients
worry you'd have people watching out on
them is - how to make laws - where if
it's legalized the size of those
businesses has to be [ __ ] managed and
controlled yeah yeah Emily regulated so
they just don't become goddamn [ __ ]
prostitution empires yeah I mean because
I would just think that you'd have a
whole [ __ ] corporate trade of human
flesh yeah you know I mean you'd add
there'd have to be some kind of checks
where they would be some nothing but
small businesses like you make it so
they cannot become incorporated yeah so
they can't make it over the right size
and make it so right they can't have us
you know that they can only be that each
owner of the business can only have a
maximum a number number of [ __ ]
people working for him that kind of [ __ ]
yeah they could put caps on it right
they could do that easily that's how I
would run it you know you'd have to work
all the kinks out and everything but
yeah I mean you know and not only would
benefit the women too because like I
said they'd have protection they would
have health screenings they would have
you know somebody look is somebody
watching their back like to make sure
that like [ __ ] creeps and weirdos
weren't coming in there and [ __ ] but
yeah so I don't even remember how we got
off on that discuss how we made on him
down flash I mean it's kind of a similar
time yeah yeah it's about what yeah cuz
I was kind of talking about when you
were going to get a drink I was talking
about how um how Michelle Knight look at
a little bit of the short end of the
stick just because you know she kind of
came from a troubled family and she had
run away from home before and you know
all there was all this stuff about her
kids so I think people you know didn't
respond to her the same way that they
responded to the other two victims maybe
and that's why kind of a shame so um so
after Gina DeJesus was taken about a
year later somebody came forward and
they had like a composite sketch of the
suspect now I've seen the composite
sketch it looks like Ariel Castro if he
was like skinny and his head was
stretched this way you know what I'm
saying it kind of looks like a
but not the description was Latino which
is correct
25 to 35 years of age
five-foot-ten 155 285 pounds with green
eyes a goatee and possibly a pencil-thin
beard yeah now he was actually five foot
seven so a little shorter
he was 179 pounds so I got the weight
right his eyes were Brown actually not
green but he didn't have a goatee so it
was kind of like me 5050 like I said the
the sketch kind of looks like him but
he's a lot pudgy er than the than the
sketch would have you believe got
somebody in New Zealand saying this it's
legal in New Zealand but he doesn't know
what it'd be like you don't mean the
United States cuz he doesn't you know
what I mean cuz night-night yes yeah
what was a legal limits it's legal in
the Netherlands it's legal in a lot of
places if the United States got ahold of
that nationwide we'd [ __ ] it up we yeah
we would put Trump nuts
[Laughter]
back to our truck nuts disgust America
tends to add testosterone and steroids
to everything that it [ __ ] does and a
nice little frosting of stupidity yeah
over the [ __ ] top if you can make
money with it why not make more and if
you could make more make all more do you
make all the [ __ ] is legal in Germany
legal in Greece yeah I was I was under
the impression that it was legal or at
least decriminalized in most European
countries I thought yeah but like I said
there's no Americans over there we would
have [ __ ] chains of a corporation a
whole chain of those damn brothels
there'd be prostitution drive-throughs
there would be like a Zuckerberg of
[ __ ] hookers you'd write you a driver
just like McDonald's and there'd be a
big sign and they'd have all the girls
pictures on there yeah you'd be like a
drive and they would throw them out the
window and you get like a [ __ ] and a
drive to [ __ ] do all kinds of [ __ ] we
have drive-through liquor stores but is
he crazy it would be [ __ ] crazy and
they would have specials they would do
everything yeah I could see there would
be like Starbucks
you'd be like a crusty Starbucks an AMC
Theatres and then they'd want to put one
every [ __ ] where and then a
[ __ ] would want to make a
vending machine okay where's a girl
standing in a damn box yeah America will
pervert everything like our corporations
are communist we basically go because
they know in communism and Marxism and
Europeans think well if it's Marxist or
if it's communist then the state can
take control of all this evil
corporations in order and all this evil
capitalism because the state becomes the
the [ __ ] of the producer of all the
[ __ ] production you know the center
of production the American
interpretation of that would be the
murder of the state and [ __ ]
production which would mean business
taking over the state that would mean
the corporation would be the government
the government would not become the
corporation the corporation's would
become the government so that's it just
look at the Rockefeller Foundation
that's what that was all about Melissa
says Denny's with a side order of s yeah
yeah oh yeah
America's have no [ __ ] shame none
none it's like something out of [ __ ]
idiocracy yeah we're go watch that movie
idiocracy that's the way United States
is it's not a joke that's a documentary
documentary not exaggerated at all
that's exactly what some of us are smart
now that's smart we can't help it it's
the environment here it's a very
different culture as a very what's a
good way to put it it's a very
expressive culture all right I suppose a
very expressive culture it's very
different from Korean other than Korea
all right there is only one culture
that's wild more wild than America
Brazil I grew up in Brazil too as a
young kid you better pray that Brazil
does not get money if they get money
you're [ __ ]
and they're trying to make it brazil is
[ __ ] crazy I love Brazil though but
it's that's why I'm crazy because I grew
up there but [ __ ] explains a lot
raised you Brazil is feral basically
yeah yeah
Oh way sorry this made me laugh DJ
maniac says how many times have I seen
positions available on the signboard
outside of McDonald's and not said I'll
take a 69 to go that's exactly what do
we be like exactly now just now I'm just
like cracking up alright so so in 2004
hey I'm a virgin I'm a legend for myself
I just invented that
well guess somewhere is gonna be some
camps trying to come up with that where
you can just like it'll be like it'll be
like a automat where you can just like
go in and put some like [ __ ] go in
there with your little smartphone and
like swipe it they see the buzz and of
course I'm buzzing I'm buzzing now yeah
yeah yeah it took you what is that soon
as i zoom as i get a buzz on I start
[ __ ] ran corporate yeah janitor says
Mussolini described fascism as a merger
of the spit and corporation yeah true
true but you could say the Soviet Union
was like that to the Soviet Union became
a corporation but if it were to have in
the United States it would be like
something you see out of aliens or
Prometheus where you'd have Weyland
industries you just have these
corporations [ __ ] calling the shots
which I think they kind of already do
anyway they're the ones that are buying
all these damn political all these
politicians they they're not they're not
working for us they're working for these
corporations the military in cuttin dust
the military-industrial complex and the
corporations I mean nobody's working for
me nobody's working for us yeah so 2004
America's Most Wanted did a segment on
Amanda berry and Gina DeJesus like I
said they forgot about poor Michelle
Knight because she was not considered a
missing person by this point
they also were on The Oprah Winfrey Show
and the Montel Williams Show now I'm the
Montel Williams Show and this is why
it's psychics pissed me off especially
like these [ __ ] TV psychics so we're
gonna [ __ ] Sylvia Browne I think she's
dead now yeah I remember her powerfully
I mean so she was on the Montel Williams
Show I remember that show and they were
yeah I think I remember this too and
they were asking her like Amanda Berry's
mom was on the show and they were asking
Sylvia Browne about her and Selby Brown
told Amanda Berry's mom Luana Miller
that Amanda Berry was dead so isn't that
nice and a mom believed it yeah I
remember that and it's like she was like
so upset and as she like you know she
gave some of her stuff away she took all
the pictures down because she had been
like you know kind of hoping that she
was still alive but she actually
believed with this horrible witch told
her and the sad thing was that Amanda
Berry's mom died before they got rescued
so yeah that makes me so sad yeah I
remember her man she was just a [ __ ]
hack psychic she said yeah [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] and she was on all the daytime
[ __ ] talk she was she was all over
the place on [ __ ] her although she
sat down I don't understand like why I
mean she had she had a good stage
presence she had some gravitas and it
was she was a persona of the times I
mean I think that she all went all the
way back to the 80s yeah record she was
on all those [ __ ] daytime shows man
they kind of made her a star just by
putting her on a lot but none of her
predictions ever proved to be true
they're all just [ __ ] vague [ __ ] oh
I'm seeing your dead loved one and it's
just [ __ ] poetry and it's like all
she ever said and she said this is the
only very kick yeah that's exactly what
it is and I feel like you know whenever
they asked her about this kind of [ __ ]
she always said the same thing it's like
oh they're dead and they always said
they're in water gee that's helpful
there's only lakes and rivers and
groundwater groundwater [ __ ] like
everywhere the world yeah the planets
only three-quarters water how'd you
guess that yeah it's good it's just like
it makes me [ __ ] well it's just like
the all of these psychics and
laying down yes in the thing about this
you can tell one in water like I said
that could be anywhere - you know it's
really shitty that she told the mom that
Amanda Barry was dead but you have to
say she's a psychic and they play the
statistics they know what is most likely
most of the time when a girl that ages
kidnaps most of the time they are dead
so she knew that and that's why she said
that because she's probably like well
that's what's most likely they stick was
like what's most likely because then
that's more likely for them to get a hit
you know I mean they know like
statistics and stuff I don't know if
they do it like deliberately but they
know what's more common to happen and
they know that that's what they will say
cuz then if it's right then everybody
will think they're [ __ ] psychic that's
how that [ __ ] works yeah but in this
case she was completely and totally
wrong but the sad thing like I said so I
guess her mom died like thinking that
Amanda was dead because she died in 2006
like seven years before they found her
there so I mean like I said you can't
you can't blame the parents for thinking
that because like I said nine times out
of ten when your kid is kidnapped
they're usually killed right away I mean
almost always that's why they're saying
that so it's very yes so it's very very
unusual to find them especially that
length of time leader um but it's just
sad that that the mom never knew that
she was alive that whole time and she
wasn't even that far away I mean she was
pretty much in the same neighborhood so
we almost get into part where he gets
captured um yeah sorta okay alright how
long we've been streaming for it's right
up here what do you do I can't see it
I'm gonna open in my face I can't see
okay yeah it's like it's right there
it's an hour before so yeah another
shitty thing too is that so like I said
the the berry family in the de hey-zeus
family they had like all these vigils
and they were like always on the news
and [ __ ] like that they did a must a
bunch of searches now Ariel Castro was
apparently in some of these search
parties and he also he had a son named
Anthony
it was a journalism student and Anthony
interviewed Gina's mom like for a
newspaper article like about the
disappearance of her daughter and his
dad was the one that [ __ ] took her
and he would be like he kind of got off
on being in the search for I like
talking to their parents oh I wonder
where they are blah he like got off on
that kind of [ __ ] and another thing that
he would do too was that he would he
would bring the girls like flyers and
stuff like that like missing flyers with
their picture on it because he thought
it was funny to like taught them that
their parents were looking for them and
didn't know where they were don't yeah
yeah he was just like a [ __ ] monster
just like everybody on this show that
we're talking about like all of the
perpetrators of these were just [ __ ]
monsters yeah he was getting his ass
kicked though he gets jail well he
wasn't even in jail that long he [ __ ]
killed himself
yeah no that was he but that's cuz he
knew you know what I mean they knew he
made those girls he watched those girls
up in the house for 10 11 years he
couldn't even stand one month in prison
and he hanged himself those things are
gonna [ __ ] him up it's why he did that
yeah she couldn't take it he could dish
it out he couldn't take exactly that's
what that just like makes me so mad so
yeah one so Michelle Knight like I said
she was the first one taken and she
seems to have gotten like the [ __ ] ease
the shittiest I'm not saying that
anybody not like a competition already
think has everybody got it shitty but
she kind of got the shittiest treatment
I think like he beat her up a bunch of
times
he basically tied her hands and feet
together he would like starve her for
several days at a time you know he would
rape them pretty much every day like I
said Michelle Knight got pregnant at
least five times and it was always like
induced miscarriages he would hit her in
the stomach with barbells [ __ ] like that
now they all all three girls like kind
of bonded over their shared you know
situation and they wrote in journals
Amanda Barry said that she kept track of
every single time that he raped her like
I mean she would write it down and there
because she's just like I wanted to keep
a record of it
so like later on I don't blame her yeah
like I said she's saying all of the
girls are like amazing
lay well-adjusted I don't know if I
would have come out of that situation as
poised as they seem to be I don't know I
don't know if I would have you know what
I'm saying why are you looking at me
like that oh no I'm really good yeah so
they basically eat when he remember to
feed them he would only feed them one
time a day he only let them take a
shower like maybe once or twice a week
they just had plastic buckets in the
corners of their rooms and they weren't
emptied every day so that's nice yeah um
you know they said I miss Delf mode
you're in stealth mode I'm getting ready
to go get [ __ ] you gonna go get
Dennis is Dennis gonna yeah gonna weigh
in on this [ __ ] ring what do you
think about this [ __ ]
this is somebody right this this is
somebody you you could hang out with
this is somebody that's like has some
similar pre-collection stay well I was
never really the kind of guy to keep a
woman around in her room my appetite was
insatiable uh-huh and I ran through him
pretty quick you know like a man does I
I get them and kill them and position
them and take pictures of them and I I
did bad thing you know I jerked off a
little bit you know but it's just
something man does you know he would get
upset I get kind of said keep him around
I don't I don't understand how a man
wouldn't get bored you know I mean a
woman is only so much in around I just
really can't
I don't really relate okay I can see
that I guess you know some men have
feelings I I've heard of me I mean what
could a woman really be I mean well you
know none of us with ovaries can ever
live up to the awesomeness of you know
of course yeah I'm glad that you'll
recognize that yeah you know why would
we even try like
and I get it I can understand a woman
might have an over inflated sense of
self-worth they do that sometimes it's
it's a fortune does it make sense ative
I have we're both and whenever you know
there women are just not that
interesting to keep them around for 10
years I knew you'd say go sit down now
I've spoken too much
I like how you hold him up to the
[Laughter]
Microverse you okay buddy yeah
Dennis checking on your welfare that was
like you're good god make me choke
Dennis may not be a good man but he's a
thoughtful man you know I mean he's sure
he looks out for a brother okay he was
never really a big drinker so he can't
really relate he keeps warning me I told
you drama it's gonna take a stroll you
need Jesus
yeah Tom you need Jesus I know some
really good churches and good pastor you
might need to talk to somebody we need
to take care of your eternal soul men
have those you know thank you very much
man let me see em flash bulbs all right
okay so like I said Michelle Knight had
up to five miscarriages also ended up
losing her hearing the one ear I believe
she had some vision problems as well
from him feeding her she needed facial
reconstruction surgery when she got out
has nerve damage also she said that for
a little while
she had oh thank you nilly
she had a thank you thank you she had a
thank everybody you know Tommy she you
need to have me on more often they're
sending you when you call those
flashbulbs I thought you're gonna put
him down in his little heads gonna share
that you're a millionaire even though
these are terrible terrible warmed up I
know it's like I'm still only on the
first case [ __ ] I know I might have a
sound I have to make you take a break
well yeah are you okay yeah I got two
more cases it's gonna be a long show
guys yeah that's alright hope you guys
are ready for this [ __ ] it's just gonna
push three hours I told you we should
only done two we're oil on them by the
time I get to the end I'll probably
we're spoiling these people we're gonna
be taking breaks during the show people
so go ahead and you know get ready for
that yeah I mean we're not gonna take
both of us breaks out at the same time
use the restroom or whatever go find the
kitty yeah check on cats
yeah so Michelle also said that for a
little while while she was trapped in
the house she had a little dog for a pet
and Ariel I guess like he was trying to
get at Michelle and the dog bit him you
know good dog but then Ariel broke the
dog's neck yeah that [ __ ] needed
to die so again like I said it's bad
enough look you keep three women
prisoner for ten years that's enough but
even if he hadn't done that if you would
just like snapped a dog's neck you needs
us to go to prison for that even before
you even do any of that other [ __ ]
that's just put that's just putting that
cherry on top of the [ __ ] no sensor hurt
he's a kind of damn domestic animal why
would you do that unless you're going to
eat it but
you don't eat dogs no yeah so Christmas
Day 2006 like I said Amanda berry had
gotten pregnant and for whatever reason
I guess because Amanda berry she was
treated horribly obviously but I think
she was treated a little bit better than
Michelle Knight because I think Ariel I
don't know but he almost I think he
called her wifey so I think she was like
his favorite breath so she was pregnant
and she was gonna give birth on
Christmas Day of 2006 and Ariel
basically he got like this blow-up
kiddie pool and like brought in this
just she could give birth in the pool so
that it wouldn't get you know blood and
crap everywhere and he told Michelle you
have to assist with the birth and if the
kid dies I'm gonna kill you
so as it happened because they're giving
us a baby thank you very very much
Melissa was a cult and pokey startup
buddy
she would like that i think i'd like to
thank you Melissa I'd also like to get
to know you a little bit better yeah
would you like to meet me at church are
you gonna bring like rope and watch a
mask bring a ladies mask and my Merry
Widow and my [ __ ] car bill yeah so as
it happened because this poor young
woman Amanda was giving birth in this
[ __ ] shitty house under in captivity
the baby actually did stop breathing but
Michelle was actually able to revive the
girl and the little girl lived Danny
so no training yeah I'm just I mean
these girls are like [ __ ] heroes man
seriously I don't know it just blows my
mind I don't know I don't know how they
[ __ ] live through this [ __ ] so as I
said previously
Ariel Castro was like super proud of
this kid and like totally went around
saying that it was like his
granddaughter even though he said that
it was like not related to him related
but like it was his girlfriend
kid she had pictures of her in a phone
and the phone and everything and
apparently let the kid he kind of gave
the kid more freedom like once she got a
little bit older you know what one of
the saddest things I was watching like
it just almost right before we started
recording I was watching an interview
with Amanda berry once Jocelyn the
little girl got a little bit older she's
like oh I made her a pretend
kindergarten like she made her like a
little classroom like in their [ __ ]
captivity room and she's like so every
morning we would get up and I would
pretend that I was walking her like
we're walk across the street and here's
the green light and here's the red light
like she would pretend like she was
taking like walking her down the street
to school and then she would drop her
off like in the corner where the
kindergarten stuff was and then she
would pretend that she was someone else
like she was her teacher like because
she wanted her to have like a normal
school experience isn't that [ __ ] up I
was like that [ __ ] that broke my
she's probably having that now though
yeah I hope so I mean and I kind of hope
because the little girl was six when
they were rescued so I kind of hope I
don't remember a lot of [ __ ] from when I
was six so I'm kind of hoping that you
know she she's like has a normal life
when like I said the ones that you know
that the three girls that were
foreigners she's like 10 or 12 now you
know are traumatized obviously but they
you know they seem to have come out of
it pretty well you know thankfully so
apparently so here's the thing so they
these girls are in the house for 10
years it's like the cops actually did go
to the house at one point like to talk
about something else it didn't have
anything to do with the kidnappings they
never suspected him of that um but he
wasn't home so they didn't like press it
and I guess he got interviewed for it's
like somewhere else and like he never
got caught now later on I think those
are the girls were rescued like
neighbors came forward later and said
hey we saw some weird [ __ ] and we
reported it but there are no records of
that now I'm not saying that they didn't
report it I'm just saying that the cop
said that they don't know records right
of them reporting any unusual activity
so it's so it's perfectly yeah little
[ __ ] you know believable is that
somebody did report lie
okay I saw this weird thing or I heard
like someone screaming I heard something
or something and they just didn't like
keep a record of it I mean that is -
they get a lot of that yeah so also so
Ariel Castro son Anthony he said that
really no one was allowed to go in the
house and that there were parts of the
like you could just come in like the
main part but it's like even when
Ariel's mom would come over she he'd
kind of make her like stay like either
on the porch or just like in the front
part of the house like he wouldn't let
anybody go anywhere in the house and
they were like all these places where
they weren't supposed to go and they
thought it was weird but not weird
enough that you know they thought too
much about it you know what I mean like
I said it's easy to say in retrospect
cuz like duh obviously three girls were
being kept prisoner in there but I never
would have thought that you that's what
I mean it wouldn't occur to you because
it's like unusual somebody asked cable
telephone internet repairman never had
to enter the home I guess not
it's like I think they did have like a
couple people did come in they're like
technicians and stuff but I guess they
didn't really he was stashed him he had
a place underneath the dam yeah you know
and we probably and he had them to a
point where he's like I'm just can make
any noise I'll kill you he had him
pretty well trained towards it towards
the middle part of it and once and like
I said and he did like back it up
because he would like I said he would
test them and like he would beat the
[ __ ] out of them like all the time and
they were terrified of him
so and he would kind of leave him
hostage over each other yeah if you [ __ ]
up I'll beat her and then once Amanda
had a kid that probably gave him some
more leverage cuz he said I'll take your
kid away or I'll do something terrible
to her and you know no one wanted that
to happen yeah by the time they got
caught they he had them pretty much
under control but you know like I said
he ran out one day and they [ __ ] it'd
break for ya now the thing about it is
that they're not really sure like I said
he seemed like after they caught him
like I'll get into that in a minute but
after they caught him he said he was a
sex addict he said he he called himself
cold-blooded he had also he said that he
hadn't really planned to kidnap
I'm like it wasn't some big it wasn't
like BTK like who had the big like
projects or where he would like months
and months I thought you don't even one
second compare me to this oh I did I
stand apart yeah yeah
Jaycee Dugard that was another that was
another case I wanted to do that was
like a similar kind of case to this were
someone was she was in the house I think
for 18 years so that's gonna be like a
when we do a volume 2 I'll do that one
but yeah so Ariel was saying that he
didn't really plan this ahead it was
just kind of like a crime of opportunity
I guess he had been wanting to like
especially I feel like after his wife
left and I guess he didn't have any
women around to beat up on so I guess
when he just like saw a little young
woman walking down the street he's like
hey I could just take her my house and
chain her up and like beat the [ __ ] out
of her and get her pregnant that just
seemed and okay let's do that and like
it seemed like he didn't put a great
deal of thought into it and they did say
later like when they interviewed him
that he was fully expecting to get
caught at some point because he wasn't
you know super secretive about it and
also when they raided his house they did
find a suicide note that he had written
and he said that any money that he had
should be given to the girls okay which
I thought was very weird yeah but I
don't know it's like it's like after
they caught him like all the [ __ ] that
he said in his trial it's like he seemed
like he was kind of apologizing but then
he was like victim blaming and then he
was just kind of like oh poor me I have
a sex addiction I'm addicted to poor and
I'm this on the other so it seemed like
he was you know [ __ ] yeah I definitely
think he was full of crap but he
definitely seems like someone who didn't
put a great deal of thought into this
with this dude I don't think it was the
sex I think it was the power yeah I
definitely think I mean yeah he took
advantage because he raped him like
pretty much every day but I don't think
that's what the main thing was yeah I
think was he won't have power of control
over people yeah I mean he definitely
really liked them just I mean whatever
he wanted they were just at his whim
they couldn't leave they couldn't do
anything they wanted no dudes gonna do
that just for sex no
I mean yeah because that's yeah yes not
efficient that's like a whole other
[ __ ] level of [ __ ] yep so finally
comes May 6th 2013 now the girls like I
said are in their respective rooms they
were in several different rooms at least
Amanda and Gina were chained together
through the wall I believe that's at
least that's how I understood from
Heather we're talking about it and the
rooms are all locked up amanda was in
there with her six-year-old Jocelyn now
Jocelyn was kind of allowed to run
around the house sort of loose you know
I mean she wasn't locked up or chained
up or anything so apparently she was
running around the house and she came
back up and said to Amanda she said Oh
like daddy or whatever she called Ariel
um you know he's gone and Amanda like
came down the steps and saw that his car
wasn't there and then she was like and
then she saw that the the big door was
kind of open like the storm door the
metal one was still closed and locked
but the big doors unusually he closed it
when he left so she thought that was
really odd and like I said at first she
was kind of scared to do anything
because she thought well he's just
testing us and he's just like around the
corner and then he's gonna come back and
I'm gonna get into trouble but then she
like kind of hung out for a couple
minutes and she didn't see anything she
didn't hear anything so then she looked
across the street because she could see
through the screen door and she saw like
a neighbor like sitting on the porch so
she decided she was just gonna [ __ ]
go for it and she started there was like
a little gap in the door like about that
wide she stuck her arm through and
started waving her arm around and
started screaming like for someone to
help her
so the first neighbor to come over there
was named angel or on Hill Cordero and
he ran over there to see what the
problem was he couldn't speak much
English so he didn't understand what she
was saying at first and then the
infamous Charles Ramsey ran over not
infamous
oh yeah it's just in the fact that he
became a meme
yeah like afterwards just because of his
interview it was like so funny and
everything so he came over and between
him and the other guy they they couldn't
get the door open because it was
locked but they ended up like kicking
out like a panel like at the bottom of
the storm door and she crawled out like
holding Jocelyn and she immediately told
them I'm Amanda berry and Charles Ramsey
said he knew exactly who that was cuz
you've been all over the news and
everything like that he's like I
couldn't [ __ ] believe it so then they
went over to like another neighbor's
house and they called 9-1-1 the 911 call
has since become also very famous where
she's like my man debería I've been a
prisoner for 10 years I'm free now and
then when the cops came you know and
told them that you know the two other
girls in the house now when the cops
went in the house apparently Gina
DeJesus ran out of the room and jumped
right into the cops arms was like you
saved me
so I was like yeah what I mean so it's
like the cops couldn't [ __ ] believe
it I mean they thought that these girls
were dead or had run away or something
like that and they've been in this
[ __ ] house for ten [ __ ] years and
it's just like when I would make your
career if you were a cop well yeah I
mean that's the thing so they took them
all to the hospital and Amanda and Gina
were pretty much okay Jocelyn was pretty
much okay they were only there for like
a day and then they were let go Michelle
was actually there for several days
because she was in a little bit worse
shape
they couldn't it was funny because I saw
like an interview with like one of the
nurses or doctors that was there like
when they all came in and stuff and like
she was just she just couldn't get over
it like how [ __ ] crazy it was cuz
everybody I mean particularly Amanda
berry she was probably the most famous
one because her parents had you know
she'd been all over the news and
everything and this this nurse she's
like I just kept looking at her like I
couldn't believe like that it was her
and she was still alive because it'd
have been ten [ __ ] years since she
disappeared sad thing was though it's
like when they went in there cuz like I
said Ariel didn't come home until later
so he didn't even probably know it was
going on like when they got everybody
out of the house but they were kind of
hoping when they went in there because
there had been this other woman who
named Ashley summers and she had
disappeared from Cleveland in awe in
July of 2007 um and they were kind of
hoping that when they found these three
girls and that they would find Ashley
summers as well because they didn't know
where the hell she was however I am sad
to report that they still do not know
where she is she is still missing as of
June 2020 so they still
know where she is they don't know if
she's a runaway because she did have a
fight with her parents like that was the
last time she was seen but um you know I
don't know where she's been said son so
kasher gets arrested a couple days later
may 6 2013 now he initially they
actually initially took two of his
brothers into custody because they
thought they had something to do with it
but then they determined that they
didn't know anything about it so they
let them go now
they gave him essentially they gave him
a plea deal they said look if you plead
guilty because he initially was gonna
plead not guilty because he was like
coming up with some [ __ ] like you
know Oh most of this he said most of the
sex I had with them was consensual most
of most of it yeah I'm like okay that's
that's not how that works but okay and
um yeah but those are the three or four
they carry ten years each but uh yeah so
he was trying to say that and then he
was talking about how much quote-unquote
harmony there was in the home and
blah-dee-blah so he was kind of trying
to paint a good thing about it so he was
initially gonna plead not guilty but
then they said look we'll give you a
plea deal I don't know if Ohio still is
the death penalty or not maybe he was
trying to get out of the death penalty
but basically he ended up pleading
guilty to like nine hundred something
charges of like rape kidnapping
they gave him aggravated murder because
of all the miscarriages that he had
caused so he got consecutive like a
whole bunch of consecutive life
sentences so it was essentially like a
thousand years in prison yeah there's no
possibility of parole or anything and
they I mean the judge basically said you
know taking this plea deal you are never
getting out I mean a thousand years no
parole no nothing no anything and he
said that he understood that and um you
know but at his hearing he was saying oh
you know porn addiction he's had sexual
problems just like [ __ ] Danna yeah he
was also fined $100,000 they took all
his property like I said his house was
in foreclosure anyway but they wasn't
his press so it wasn't really his
property anymore anyway because he
didn't pay his [ __ ] property taxes
and they ended up tearing it down
everyone was [ __ ] sick looking at it
so before he got sentenced he actually
stood up there for 20 minutes kind of
trying to mitigate I guess somewhat and
he's like saying he was not a monster he
says he's a good person I'm like I'm
pretty sure you don't know what that
phrase means but okay I don't understand
why guys doing all this kind of [ __ ]
tries to kiss ass afterwards it's like
you're going to prison okay it's not
nothing you say now is good I firmly
fiendish on the [ __ ] gone I did
it and I [ __ ] loved it and I know
that she hated and [ __ ] y'all and if you
was there out of dart to you too and you
better pray that you don't see me again
I don't why not well now wait I might as
well use like you know you're getting
out of there you're not getting out of
there well just [ __ ] just well in a
way it's like more offensive what he did
because you know he doesn't feel bad
right you know he doesn't feel bad he
probably does think he's a good person
I'd have gone out like a g5 [ __ ] you all
I didn't just bear it to make you all
suffer you know I hate you you didn't
pull the carl panzram yeah yeah whatever
that [ __ ] that he said before they
better hope I don't escape if you judge
I'm coming for you I just said all kinds
of crazy [ __ ]
like put me head me all over television
like I said you might as well but yeah
[ __ ] him out I've make all kinds of
angry faces and [ __ ] but speaking of
which we were watching I just reminded
me of like [ __ ] we were talking about
last night we were watching that Gordon
Ramsay 24 hours to hell and back show
like a to be yeah and you were making
you're particularly laughing at this one
expression that Gordon was making yeah
yeah and he said he's like we need to
like quit print that out and like put it
in a frame and then I'm gonna put it my
office and then anytime I feel like I'm
not like lazy or not get my work done I
could just look up and have Gordon
looking at me sternly and disapproving
yeah one can make a face can make a face
to make you look like [ __ ] it really was
a good thing go back and look at it see
if I can do it I told him I said now I'm
get one of those you know long frames
they have like three or four different
like slots in it oh okay whoa oh whoa
thank you very much that's awesome but
yeah so I said I'm gonna get one of
those like [ __ ] frames with all the
with all the slots in it and I'm just
gonna put a whole bunch of different
like Gordon Ramsay expressions in there
like I'm gonna put one of him like
looking at you like I can't believe
you're this stupid I'm gonna put one of
him lower it looks like he's yelling and
like pointing at you and it's like then
it'll be like motivational you know I
mean business it'll be really funny so
yeah so yeah he says he's a good person
and addicted to sex practice the art of
masturbation from a young age there's a
it's an art yeah you trying to say he's
a jackoff artist yes
there ought to be a job what exactly is
a jack oh wow look around the corner
[Laughter]
trying to get creative which I know what
I mean there's art to everything how
much does the jack artist make yeah he
says and he said he never beat or
tortured the women which is [ __ ]
[ __ ] in flash bow thank you and yeah
easy [ __ ] money cars good work if you
think I gotta say some crazy [ __ ] yeah
thing is I can't invent crazy [ __ ] just
gotta come from a soul
well like you said you're channeling I
just got a channeling so like I said
another thing that he's another special
thing that he's said to other than
blaming the girls for getting into a car
with a stranger even though they knew no
no he was um was also that he was also
kind of blaming them because he's like
oh you know I raped them and discovered
that they weren't virgins oh it's a
shame on them this dear
horse yeah but like what he did was fine
yeah oh yeah of course it's his duty his
duty as a man what is with these
[ __ ] nuts man he's [ __ ]
crazy
god dammit he's trying to mitigate it
make himself look better make it look
worse it's like [ __ ] off
deal what you dealing with a [ __ ]
psycho yeah so you know happily like I
said happily
this dude was only in prison for a month
and then he decided to do a do the world
a favor that's cuz him other dudes were
like hang his own ass most of the other
dudes were listening listening to what
he was did what he did on [ __ ] TV and
then they saw his [ __ ] [ __ ] ass up
there [ __ ] mope and cry about being
locked up and they're like [ __ ] you had
them girls locked up for ten years
[ __ ] put money 11 years as a min old
situation and then they're [ __ ] with
him they're like you had him locked up
so you can get that [ __ ] we're gonna
guessing that [ __ ] from you last
Arielle that's a girl's name in area
just like the Little Mermaid that's
right we're gonna have that hair dyed
red put some like that yeah [ __ ]
making some little high heels and [ __ ]
be [ __ ] out of flip-flops those
shower shoes make a little [ __ ]
g-string for him and [ __ ] I mean I
really didn't need that mental image get
out of here I gotta get out of here I
gotta protect my boy [ __ ] and [ __ ]
you know he [ __ ] exited got early
release early released by hanging that's
what happened which in a way is kind of
a shame he should have had to suffer but
yeah in a way like no one's gonna cry
that [ __ ] dead really I mean um
and honestly like I said it really does
seem like the girls you know young women
obviously have you know really adjusted
very well their situation you know they
come out um Amanda berry she does like
some new segments and stuff like that
helps out volunteers with missing
children charities and stuff um it's
kind of sad though because Michelle
Knight she went on she got married um
she had the kid Joey
that um was taken away from her you know
what I mean that she was going because
remember on the day she got kidnapped
she is going to the hearing and I got a
react yes he did he child he child
I'll
demand himself did not take his own life
yeah but Ariel The Little Mermaid did
take his own life although like I said I
think that was like too easy on him but
I'm not gonna cry because he's dead yeah
yeah because he's a terrible person but
you do kind of want him to suffer
at least to the extent that his victim
suffered if that's even we got to do is
we got to do a show on child Island man
we probably will get around to it
eventually I'm sure yeah but um yeah so
the shitty thing is that Michelle like I
said she changed her name to Lili
Rosalie I think and she did actually end
up getting married she wanted to have
more kids of her own but because of all
the abuse and torture that he put her
through she's now infertile as far as
they know so she can't have any more
kids of her own she wanted to get back
in touch with her son Joey who when I
saw the interview he was 18 like when
she was talking about him but she was
like well I don't you know I don't want
to necessarily involve him in like all
this [ __ ] up [ __ ] like all the media
circus around the case and everything
like that
and it seems like he got adopted by the
foster family that he was with like when
he got taken away from her and they I
don't know if there's any like act if
it's acrimonious but they didn't really
want him to see her but at this point
he's an adult so I'm assuming and I
really kind of hope that they
reconnected at some point because I kind
of feel like all this time they thought
she was a runaway and so the son was
probably told well your mom took off and
didn't want you and that wasn't what
happened like she got kidnapped so I
kind of hope that you know that that was
resolved because you know he had
probably gone so many years with the
foster parent selling you know your mom
didn't want you anymore
ran away and left and she hadn't so I
really kind of hope that that got
resolved it hadn't been resolved she
hadn't met up with him like one of the
interview that I saw but that was like a
year or two old so I'm not really sure
how that turned out but like I said I've
seen other very recent interview
with the three girls and they all seem
to be doing really well like I said
Ariel cashers death you know even though
for a time they thought maybe it was
auto-erotic asphyxiation like they
wondered if he'd accidentally when he
was like doing his jackoff artist thing
like trying to be creative with it but
so you break you double down and bring
back the jackoff artist I love this well
that was only like a couple you gotta do
like some callback you talked like it
was like three weeks ago it was just
like five minutes ago he said that but
he had actually like set up a little
shrine and [ __ ] like that so they do
think that it was actually suicides
you're relatively sober compared to be
relatively I might as okay so um yeah so
like I said they tore the house down so
there's just like a [ __ ] empty lot
now and show like that so happily you
know wasn't happy what happened to them
and they went through [ __ ] horrible
torture for ten years but they came out
of it alive and they seem to be doing
very well and Ariel Castro is [ __ ]
dead and rotting in the earth somewhere
so Ariel Castro The Little Mermaid that
couldn't perfect opposite this I don't
know and it's just it weirds me out so
much like oh I think one of the things
that weirds me out the most about these
cases is that this kind of [ __ ] can just
be happening and you're like your
next-door neighbor's doing that [ __ ] and
they don't know you know what I mean
here just like Charles Ramsey said it's
like the guy was totally normal like I
said he played bass he was like one of
the best bass players yeah in Cleveland
he was in a salsa band like he would go
every night like he played in this band
and nobody knew a thing like he was like
pretty popular he'd go to all the
neighborhood barbecues and everyone just
thought he was totally [ __ ] normal and
he had three [ __ ] girls like locked
up in this [ __ ] house so you wanted
the next case now yeah break it off um I
think I'm all right at the moment I
think I'm gonna take a break you good
hit hold on well I can't just like
standing or like looking at answer
questions I might have to like go to the
bathroom after you
I'm thinking about it yeah a dead
giveaway that's what that's what I was
saying earlier it's like I can't listen
to like Charles Ramsey talk without
hearing that song that somebody made
it's like we ate ribs with this dude
like all this other kind of [ __ ] because
he was just like instantly nameable and
like the [ __ ] that he said about he knew
something was wrong when a pretty little
white girl ran into a black man's that's
why everybody cracked up because it's
like he was just kind of telling it like
it is now he did write a book and it's
called dead giveaway and then it has
like this really long subtitle like
hamburgers the rescue white folks and
something else
um and I haven't read it like it seems
like it got good reviews like some
people said he's kind of they liked it
cuz he was like a very honest and
refreshing person but also that he was
good not so much an [ __ ] but I don't
know I don't really know how to describe
it but I kind of want to read it he
seemed like a fascinating character like
and he was on like a lot of this work in
TV shows after but uh oh my god she read
a dear Prudence column once where a
person was worried a relative might have
someone locked up in his house it's like
man it's it just seems like that's the
last thing you would think of like with
relatives and [ __ ] but in some cases it
has to be true because some people have
done that and I mean the next case we're
gonna talk about the Fritzl case which
is the [ __ ] one thing that blew my
mind about this case was when they
caught this [ __ ] when they
caught Josef Fritzl he basically like at
his at his trial or at his sentencing he
basically said something to the effect
of like he was trying to make it seem
like what he did wasn't so bad because
man just look at other people's houses
and you'll find all kind of girls in
basements and stuff like that and I'm
like do you really think that just
because you did that that like a whole
bunch of other people do it as well it's
like other people do it but I'm sure
it's a tiny tiny tiny fraction of a
percentage it's like does he really
think Oh everybody doesn't so it's okay
if I do it too
it just really seemed like that was the
attitude that he had like it was okay
because other people did it so he wasn't
so bad because other people had secrets
like that too which to me seems like
really [ __ ] up but yeah um I kind of
wanted to get started on it but okay
your Byakugan
okay cookies back in yeah
yeah you take a breaker um yeah you
talked for a minute I'm gonna run to the
bathroom and then we'll go on and talk
about the Josef Fritzl case yeah all
right everybody it's just me and y'all
what do we got going on with everybody
so you guys enjoying the show so far
sky with okay I've never sit in a big
cabin chair I'm in the cab his chair
what's up Zanna how you doing bro yeah
Susie rocks Susie rocks see what she's
got going on here she's got a lot of
notes and everything okay so Maddie
you're signing you wrote your divorce
Monday huh all right everybody's
enjoying the show [ __ ] Jonna blah ha
there's a guy called Jason blah ha do
you have any idea who that you know who
that is
Jason blah is the biggest fitness
[ __ ] faking all the it all YouTube ok
back yeah I'm in a cab chair did you
talk bad about me wall yeah me and
Dennis are running in 2020
oh my god alright alright so you want to
talk about this
the Fritzl case yeah this guy's great
greatest moustache of all times this one
this guy it's it you know it's like hard
to tell when sometimes when you look at
pictures of people like you know serial
killers are psychopaths or whatever but
this guy looks like a [ __ ] psychopath
I mean when you see the picture of him
you're just like oh of course
that's of course exactly what he would
look like so this happened they didn't
find out about it until 2008
this happened in Austria in a town
called am Stephanie now
so Josef Fritzl was this guy and okay he
look like something out of damn there
was a movie back in the day called a
great race yeah the great race was
supposed to be taking place like so in
the early 1900's they were getting these
old [ __ ] cars and then race all the
way around the earth and they had one
team it was it was the bad guys they had
what was the name of the [ __ ] snidely
whiplash no not what was his name do you
remember the nose oh yeah I know you
talked about it was Jack Lemmon and the
other guy I don't remember the name of
that [ __ ] team but he looked like
something from the great race yeah what
was that guy's name in it it were all
black they were kind of good with
[ __ ] top hats yeah at a black car
with a [ __ ] red spike on the [ __ ]
front of it they got red hot yeah and
I'm trying to remember what the name of
it
those guys were anyway this dude looked
like he looked like he should be on that
racing team yeah he had the black hair
and a little [ __ ] up Mustang I didn't
even like a [ __ ] up mustache um it
wasn't a handlebar mustache you know
just Billy he looked like something from
the from the from the early 1900's well
he grew up in like Austrian like the
Nazi era yeah you know he seemed to have
some Nazi tendencies I think that's kind
of why why do you say that because it
was like [ __ ] that he did later on he
was a very very very like in
to discipline and imprisonment and he
was just like my bondage dude no it
wasn't anything to do with bondage you
maybe maybe you're thinking of a
different this is the guy who [ __ ]
trapped his own daughter yeah yeah I
remember for 24 years
yeah in Austria he was this [ __ ]
pervert though yeah I don't think a
hanging do it politics no I'm just
saying that he that he grew up during
that era and he later on said that he
was like kind of into that kind of [ __ ]
like in that and it kind of like
influenced his upbringing a lot
he liked sadomasochism yeah well yeah
well like you know strict discipline he
was really really strict into them well
that's always been there in that era era
yeah they had a really good military
they trained our army back in the
seventeen hundreds of Prussia
you know our army was based on a
Prussian system of training which is
brutal yeah brutal discipline Terry
Thomas the name was the name of the
actor and the great race yeah yeah yeah
I remember that
it wasn't me what would the name of
those characters though do you guys
remember I can't remember that's
professor fate that's what his name was
professor fate yeah and he look like
Professor faith to me great movie
actually yeah I haven't seen in a long
time
yeah so all right so he's born in uh
Austria in the town where all this [ __ ]
took place now when he was 21 he married
a woman named Rose Marie who was 17 at
the time now he would end up with her he
would have four daughters and three sons
now his daughter their daughter
Elizabeth who was the woman that would
later become his captive was born in
1966 now he started sexually abusing her
reportedly when she was 11 years old now
she actually um she finished school when
she was 15 and then she was gonna go on
and she was gonna be a waitress however
because she had been sexually abused for
several years at this point she ran away
from home
understandably
so she went to Vienna and stayed with a
friend of hers but the police found her
three weeks later and took her back home
now she ended up getting a job as a
waitress in 1984 and she worked there
for a little while but once she turned
18
her father decided that later on he said
it was because she wouldn't listen to
him or she was rebellious or something
like that which like I said it sounds
like a bunch of crap I think it was just
because she was 18 she had a job he was
afraid she was gonna move out so he
thought well I better do something about
this so very shortly after she turned 18
he basically said hey come down to the
basement of it I need you to help me
with something so she goes down there to
help him she helps him carry a door like
this big door and then once she dad they
get the door into the frame they get it
in place and everything like that and
then he had like a towel that was soaked
in ether and he put it over her face and
knocked her out and then locked her in
the basement now it should be noted that
this dude planned this for a really long
time now notably he had been in prison
before for rape and attempted rape when
he was younger like in his 20s he said
that he had gotten the idea of like
building a bunker to keep a woman in
like while he was in prison for that and
he would later say that he was
quote-unquote born to rape and so he
needed like an outlet for that or he
would be a lot worse that's kind of what
he was getting at so he had he had come
up with this idea of doing this basement
thing so he this took several years of
planning for him to do because this
wasn't just like oh he threw his
daughter in like a normal a spaceman and
kept her down there and nobody knew
about it it was like another house this
was like a [ __ ]
a basement that was like behind the
basement the sub-basement there are like
eight [ __ ] doors that you had to go
through there were like locked and two
of them were like electronic locks he
was an engineer like he had trained in
engineering so he had like this really
elaborate you know system and like the
door into the thing there was only one
door that you could go into then like I
said it was this whole network of like
[ __ ] doors that was all underground
and everything was like behind it was
like a secret passage it was like behind
a bookshelf like in his office or
something like that so nobody knew that
it was really back there
his cover story for when he initially
built it was that he was building a bomb
shelter which a lot of people were doing
at the time so what nobody thought it
was that weird so like I said it's not
the kind of case where it was just like
oh they were just right there in the
basement and nobody knew anything about
it this was like a very thought-out
that's what's so creepy about this
[ __ ] case is that he had thought out
every [ __ ] detail about this [ __ ]
yeah the only didn't he didn't think I
was a ventilation it didn't have any
ventilation so it was constantly [ __ ]
really moist a lot of comments it was
yeah it was really a lot of bad air in
it yep and it was small it was only
about I think it was only 500 or 600
square feet yeah it had like a hot plate
it had a bathroom it had a couple
bedrooms but it was very very small and
the ceiling was really low and it was
really sad because one of the kids she
had when she was in there who will get
into that um he ended up being when he
grew up he was 5 foot 8 and the ceiling
was only 5 at 6 so when they were
eventually let out he has permanent
spinal problems because he constantly
had to crouch down all this he couldn't
stand up straight um so this is like
just a [ __ ] up situation all around
so he has built this [ __ ] basement
compound which he called a bunker and he
has locked Elisabeth down in it now he
has like I said he's planned everything
ahead so she disappears her mom files a
missing-persons report as you would now
a month after that um Joseph comes
forward and he had he says he has a
letter from his daughter and it is
indeed from his daughter because he has
forced her to write it in the basement
but the mom didn't know that the cops
didn't know that so basically what the
letter said was that Elizabeth said that
she was she didn't want to live with her
family anymore
and she had gone off to stay with a
friend she's like please don't look for
me or I'll leave the country and the
letter was postmarked from like some
other city because he had made her write
it and then he had driven to another
city and mailed it back to his own house
so like I said he thought all of this
[ __ ] through so he basically told
everybody that well she just she was mad
at us and she ran off and she joined a
religious cult so and she doesn't want
us to look for her so that's kind of how
he deflected all of the issues you know
of her just being there the whole time
you know what I mean so and you know
every now and then like he would make
her write a letter you know saying where
she was or something like that which is
why like nobody looked for her and like
I said she had run away before and he
was a very well-respected figure like in
the neighbor like he had he was kind of
like had a nice job it was like a decent
house um even though he had been
convicted of rape and attempted rape
previously like in his 20s um it had
enough time had passed that it wasn't on
his record anymore like it had been
expunged so so no one had any reason to
like think anything was wrong because
you know Elizabeth had been troubled
before and he you know he said that she
ran away to join a cult so everyone just
kind of believed that so the next 24
years
Joseph basically goes down into the
basement every day or at least like
several times a week rapes her everyday
brings food he basically what he would
do he just said told his wife he would
go down there like in the morning and
said that he was working down there like
that was his secret basement thing and
she wasn't allowed to go in there
and you know sometimes he would even
sleep down there and you just say oh
he's just working really hard doesn't
imagine that [ __ ] this is your dad doing
this [ __ ] measured the [ __ ] that's right
this like [ __ ] blows my mind I might
yeah so because of all the rain psycho
yeah because of all the rapes she got
pregnant seven times now one of the
children uh was a boy and he died only a
few days after he was born and Joseph
took the body up and burned it in the
incinerator the other six children lived
and they just lived in this [ __ ]
small bunker with their mom and
sometimes according to her Joseph would
rape her in front of the kids just to
humiliate her damn so there was that
whole thing and then another thing that
he would do and they're not entirely
sure why he did this either because they
were running out of room down there or
he was afraid that the kids were gonna
make too much noise and he would get
caught so what he started doing was the
kids who were like the youngest and the
noisiest when they were still pretty
young or too young to like remember
exactly what was going on he would take
them out of the basement and then he
would go around and he would leave them
on his own doorstep and then he would
tell the wife and the authorities that
oh my daughter Elizabeth who ran off to
join a cult if you remember this is one
of her kids and she just dumped the kid
here for us to take care of so they
essentially adopted them as foster
children and they lived in the house
with him and his wife and that was and
that was like their foster kids it's an
ingenious dastardly plan that's what I
mean dastardly that's exactly he's yeah
he looks dastardly yeah I said you look
like Professor faith from oh yeah that's
exactly so and his wife I see this in
this situation I don't like because I
know that like the wives of serial
killers and stuff
like how could they have not have known
and all this other kind of [ __ ] because
I think in a lot of ways like you know
BT Kay's wife Ted Bundy's girlfriend I
don't think that they knew what was
going on in this case I find it harder
to excuse it I'm not saying I don't know
if she knew exactly what was going on
but I find it difficult to square that
she didn't investigate further maybe she
was afraid of him I mean he did seem
like a frightening person obviously and
maybe she thought it better like not to
look too much into his affairs well he
had that underground thing and then the
door to it was hidden so maybe she just
said that's what I made me she didn't
think about it I mean it's possible the
thing is is that there was no
ventilation down there yeah and you have
six little kids in it and then a grown
woman you would think that the smell
would be pretty bad you would think that
yeah and another thing too that I I
think a lot of people don't mention is
that over the 24 years that'll never
happen the season that Elizabeth and the
children were in this bunker
they had um tenants in the building like
they rented out rooms like over this 24
years I believe it was somewhere in the
order of like a hundred different people
and a couple of them did say it's like
sometimes they would hear weird things
like in the basement but Joseph would
always say something like oh it was just
like faulty pipes or you know or a gas
leak or something he would always come
up with an excuse and like you said no
one really that's not the first thing
that you jump to is that someone's
keeping someone in the [ __ ] basement
I mean because how often does that a 1
in 6 of the kids right so you wouldn't
think that so if somebody just told you
you know the pipes are shitty or
whatever you just be like oh okay
you would just probably buy it yeah so I
don't know so I know a lot of people do
like kind of [ __ ] on his wife for not
knowing or at least being so in curious
and what I think it's not so much that
like she didn't know that there was like
a bunker because like I said why would
you think that but I think people were
mad because she seemed like she didn't
look for Elizabeth too hard and there
if your daughter ran off and like join a
cult it's like if you were their mom
wouldn't you look for them harder
instead of just maybe not yeah I guess
it is grown up and you tell my Germans
they're pretty reserved
well Austria Austrians got the same
thing same kind of culture though and
this is a pretty big house from what I
remember it is yeah it was a pretty big
house so I think it would be easier to
hide him in a bigger house yeah I guess
so and like I said if there were like
lodgers and stuff staying in there maybe
that was all kinda noise and the wife
might have been coming and going a lot
and how long was it 20 years 24 years as
long as the interest to the place was
[ __ ] well hidden behind a damn
bookcase why you wouldn't think about it
you move a bookcase yeah yeah cuz like I
said it wasn't like a normal basement it
was like it was like a series of like
doors like locked doors and tunnels she
didn't know these sub-basement said he
didn't know that he was bringing [ __ ]
food down their clothing educational
material because he was sending books
down there to little kids
she's putting the little kids through
school basically yeah from what I
remember well she um the mom did teach
them to read him right and everything I
mean she she's amazing
I'm God how the hell do you explain this
situation to the kids though
look we're down here there's an outside
world you guys have never seen it
they've never we can't leave and your
dad is my dad it's like this is so
messed up it's like you can't even like
[ __ ] make this up so in 1994 that was
after the fourth kid was born geez um
Joseph like magnanimously said oh well I
guess we can make this basement like the
bunker bigger but you guys have to do
all the work and I don't think he gave
many tools or anything they just had to
like dig [ __ ] out with her hands like to
make it bigger so it was initially 380
square feet which is very very small if
you didn't know and then they expanded
it's a 590 square feet now they did have
a TV they had a radio and they had a VCR
they had a hot plate and they had a
refrigerator um sometimes like Joseph
would come down there and like watch
videos with them now Elizabeth also said
later that
you would make her watch porn and then
they would have to act it out um and
have fun yeah and then like it with the
kids there yeah because it was all this
one room it's like you know what I mean
it's not like the kids to any place so
if they did something bad or something
that Joseph didn't like Joseph would
turn their lights off you know leave
them in the dark for you know several
hours or days at a time or would not
bring them food he also had them
believing that he could gas them or that
they would be electrocuted if they
touched the door and tried to get out so
even though they later determined like
after they found her there's like
there's no way that they could have
gassed them because there was no gas
supply to the basement but the you know
they didn't know that so what ended up
happening how this [ __ ] douche got
caught after all this time like I said
at this point Elizabeth and three of the
kids are in the basement and the other
three kids live upstairs with Joseph and
his wife and don't really I mean I guess
they won't even remember anything yeah
they were probably fair they were fairly
young when they got taken away from
their mom so this so it's kind of like
two things going on and Joseph is just
like going back and forth between he's
essentially living two lives like one in
the normal house and one in the
underground house so how this
[ __ ] ended up getting caught
this happened in April of 2008 now
Elizabeth's oldest daughter whose name
was Kirsten
she got really sick um it was some kind
of like she passed out and I think it
ended up being like some kind of kidney
failure or something like that she
really had like some serious problems
how old was she at this time um which
the daughter oh yeah Kirsten for 40 no
no um she would have been oh she was the
oldest daughter I think she would have
been in her I think she was 19 okay but
the his daughter must have been by this
time about what yeah 40 something like
that yeah right
yeah because Kirsten would I believe she
was 19 when she got sick and they so
find out her whole
nineteen years yeah so Joseph finally
agreed that you know they needed to take
her to the hospital so Elizabeth and
Joseph take Kirsten out of the chamber
this is the first time she has been
outside in 24 years Elizabeth like
outside can you imagine be a big shock
yeah so after like she helped her dad
take Kirsten out of the bunker Joseph
made her go back into the bunker and
that she was in there for another week
but Joseph called an ambulance and the
ambulance came and got Kirsten
now when Kirsten got to the hospital the
doctors and nurses that were attending
her were very confused because Joseph
was kind of being um understandably
cagey about who she was
he's just like oh well she's you know my
daughter's I think he said she's my
daughter's kid and it's like you know my
daughter ran away and left or something
like that and the the hospital staff
thought it was very weird that Kirsten
did not have any record of her existence
no birth certificate no social security
number no nothing like that
and you know he wasn't telling them you
know who she was basically so they
thought that was very suspicious and
they also obviously for medical purposes
they needed to know like who the mother
wasn't everything in case that was some
kind of genetic defect and they needed
to know that but he wouldn't tell them
so joseph is like kind of being thing
and they're getting like suspicious so
he leaves and then he comes back later
and says oh well I found this note from
Karstens mom that says what you need to
know you know yeah like that that kind
of [ __ ] so at this point the hospital
staff were like yeah this is this is not
right so they called the cops so the
cops came forward and contacted the
media and the media came out and said
you know look we need this girl came up
at this hospital we need to know who her
mother is we need to know who she is
because she's gonna die because she was
like in really bad shape so
at this stage the police also reopened
the investigation into Elizabeth's
disappearance since this was Josef
Fritzl it was Elizabeth's father and
they thought that that there might be
some connection there which there was um
at this point Joseph was still trying to
like do damage control he said no she
ran away she's in a cult she just sent
me this letter and so they kind of tried
to but at this point I think like the
police we're starting to feel like his
case was kind of starting to fall apart
because they're just like look we've
never heard of a cult that's like this
one that she's talking about these
letters sound like they were dictated by
someone else so they just thought it was
very weird um so at this stage Elizabeth
finally talked her father because she
had seen like she had a TV so she had
seen like all the media and stuff like
that saying you know look this girl's
gonna die we need to know her mother is
so Elizabeth was like please let me go
to the hospital and talk to them so he
finally on April 26th he fought 2008 he
finally let her and her two other sons
whose names were Stefan and feels let
them leave the house and they went to
the hospital now the police came and
surrounded the place and like you know
detained them there now Elizabeth and
man good for her she said like the cops
were like look what the [ __ ] is going on
and everything and she said I will tell
you everything if you promise me that I
never have to see my father ever again
and the police said that they would do
that so she told them the whole [ __ ]
story measure those cops were [ __ ]
[ __ ] they're going no way this can't be
true yeah they were [ __ ] my their
minds were blown didn't they went they
didn't they went down there and found
that underground bunker and they're like
God yeah yep oh yeah so yeah so
basically the cops were like okay and
they heard the story so then they went
back they took all they took her they
took all the kids and they took Joseph's
wife and they put them all into care at
this stage Joseph knew that he was
busted
so he showed the cops how to get into
the bunker which like I said he had like
keyless entry with like the code on it
two of the doors were electronic I
believe it was it was either five doors
or eight doors they were like if so it
wasn't just like like I said it wasn't
just like walking into a door it was
just like a whole series of [ __ ]
doors that only he had the code to and
they were hidden and show like that I
would have killed that dude on a spot
yeah it's like really is there any
reason for keeping this dude around well
the only reason I imagine they would to
but but they're in a group and you know
everybody's everybody's watching you get
trouble it's not a man it's a [ __ ]
monster yeah it's a fairly monster and
you know so they did the whole DNA test
and did like actually prove that all of
the children were Joseph's biological
yeah yeah and so and I should note too
that like some of the doors that were in
between like the main door like that led
into this bunker weighed over a thousand
pounds so it wasn't kind of then there
was another door that was like 650
pounds like I said they're always like
keyless entry codes it show like that
so the thing about it is that Joseph
when he got caught you know like I said
he was a he did electrical engineering
he kind of had that thing where at first
says what's what's the deal with like
these [ __ ] up dudes and like their
relationships with their moms man
because one of the first things he said
was he thought his mom was awesome but
then later on he kind of came forward
and talked about how much she sucked and
also I think he kind of had the hots for
her it was totally [ __ ] weird it was
just like some kind of sexual pervert
yeah and basically so like I said this
wasn't his first time that he had done
something like this
it's just that in Austria particularly
this time period I guess after 15 years
like your records were expunged like
your criminal record so he had actually
in 1967 he had actually broken into a
house
and raped a 24-year old woman who was a
nurse like while her husband was out of
town
um well it dudes a psychopath and yeah a
sexual [ __ ] deviant you know he's a
rapist
yeah serial rapist and he was also um it
was also he also got arrested for an
attempted rape of a 21 year old woman
and was kind of big he would go around
doing like indecent exposure and Shelley
I guess he figured that if he [ __ ]
got his daughter he keep himself out of
trouble well that's essentially what he
said because he was saying like but
you're going like well yeah [ __ ] her to
[ __ ] my daughter I'll just use her my
for yo-you yeah she'll just be around in
the men from raping yeah that's
essentially what he said that's
eventually what he said that's a serious
[ __ ] psychopath that's a dude just
puts me yeah this guy is playing self
over everything not even that's not a
human human that's like a robot yeah
it's just a he's not even an animal cuz
that's an insult to animals animals
aren't like that that's what I mean yeah
that's like and and I kind of have a
problem with like people they call it
like people that do these kind of crimes
it's like oh it's just an animal like no
animals are awesome or than that animals
make perfect sense yeah it's like they
don't do that [ __ ] like that for no
reason come on yeah they kill [ __ ]
because it's just some [ __ ] to kill and
then they eat it or they don't eat it
yeah I mean but they don't they don't
like rape their own offspring and keep
them captive and [ __ ] although you know
there's interbreeding going on between
cats and dogs I don't know yeah but
they're not being mean yeah they're just
doing what animals do that's what I mean
it's not like it takes intelligence to
be this position right yeah yeah just
cats and cats don't know they're related
and dogs don't know they're related they
don't care yeah yeah
so the distance getting off on the wrong
this yeah I think I mean he said
something like he pulled an Ariel Castro
as well and said oh it wasn't rape
because it was consensual and whatever
fault I'm sure your daughter was like
super into it it was her fault I had to
do it it kept her out of trouble yeah
how much of a sense of [ __ ] like that
it's always it's always if I wasn't
doing this she'd be out there running
around and creamed that was kind of one
of the angles that he was coming yeah at
it
kind of a little bit like well she was
rebellious and yeah I had to keep
control she's right that's why she was
she had brought she had run away one
time and she ran away because he was
already molesting her when she was 11
she had got in trouble that's why she
ran away out of trouble that's why I
remember the remember that British
couple that was [ __ ] raping girls
together in the Fred rosemary yeah yeah
[ __ ] Fred West was like that when he
killed his own daughter yeah well she
was being bad
so I raped her and killed her why did
you yeah like you do if you know she was
she was unruly she was unruly because
she was getting away from you yeah well
I kind of feel like that was the
situation here it's like obviously he'd
been molesting her since she was 11
yeah and I think he was just afraid
because like I said she had turned 18
she had a job and she had run away to go
one she was gonna leave so I thought so
he was probably like oh well this is my
last chance so I better get her now
before she takes off and like goes and
has an adult life somewhere that's a
weird [ __ ] man
that's what I mean so it's like so he's
he kind of vacillated like I said
between kind of like Ariel kasher did I
kick that dude's dick up into his mouth
right dudes a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I
[ __ ] that dude up somebody needs that
so yeah so he's saying [ __ ] about it
being consensual kind of victim blaming
always he seemed to say and this is like
a quote from him he said I always knew
during the whole 24 years that what I
was doing was not right that I must have
been crazy to do such a thing yet it
became a normal occurrence to lead a
second life in the basement of my house
yet then he would turn around and say
just like a real cow sure did
that he's not a monster that he's not a
beast and then he would try to point out
like good [ __ ] he did you know I would
go I brought them a Christmas tree yeah
I can't I watched videos with the kids
I ate meals with them I was you know I
was nice to them and it's like what the
like that makes it okay somehow it's
like oh my god it's just like [ __ ]
it's crazy so that um yeah he said
that he had to imprison her yes see this
is that's what you said he said she did
not adhere to my rules anymore when she
became a teenager that's why I had to do
something I had to create a place where
I could keep Elizabeth by force if
necessary away from the outside world
bees nest is back good to see you back
bees nest yeah where'd you go guys still
back off
yeah we're only on the second case the
wrong the end of the second case yes um
yeah so basically they uh this guy like
I said he said that he was he tried to
like blame his mom as they all do it's
like you know look she just at first
he said she was super awesome but then
he said no she didn't love me she didn't
she never hugged me she just had me so
she could prove to my dad that she could
have children and there was all this
other stuff and they fly and yeah and
then he was talking about how much he
liked the Nazis and all this other kind
of [ __ ] he's lying so yeah so there's
all this other kind of crap he's just
trying to get off yeah he said and this
is a direct quote from him he said I was
born to rape and I held myself back for
a relatively long time willed you thank
you yes you're lucky I didn't rape more
I could have behaved a lot worse than
locking up my daughter yeah so there he
is I could be able at worse but I had to
do that otherwise all of you ah
saving you people from me yeah that's
basically what he was saying she'd be
thankful I could have been much worse
yeah so he was [ __ ] prison for life
thankfully I don't know if he's still
alive because he was old as [ __ ] like um
when he when he went but he and I was
saying this while you were in the
bathroom he basically was trying to say
that you know why don't you look in
other people's basements and you'll find
like other going and stuff like like
yeah we all have just calm and
everybody's doing that's in our face I'm
like man don't [ __ ] project
everybody's doing it you're a [ __ ]
crazy person like I said it's like how
many people have that
thankfully not very many now like I said
sadly the you know Elizabeth and the
kids and everything obviously they had
very really bad issues from I mean
particularly the children because they
have immigrant that and they had never
seen sunlight for 24 years and like I
said some were grown so a lot of them
had issues both physical and
psychological yeah they were completely
freaked out by having space to walk
around because they were so used to yeah
being in a confined space and like when
they were like allowed to run around it
like freaked them out really badly and
they would have panic attacks
um they were actually in hospitals for a
long time and after they were let out
I believe the Austrian government said
that they could have new identities if
they wanted because they really did not
want any media attention and they seem
to have been pretty good about about
kind of giving them their privacy and
leaving them alone because they have had
to take ten years to recover from that's
what I mean they've had like a lot of
issues and they had to go like through a
lot of therapy a lot of parts of their
brains would still be infantile because
they were just not [ __ ] developed
like I said spatial awareness they
probably never got that and they're um
all of their vision was bad because you
know it was so dark in there
the air was bad the molding the mold and
only focusing up close [ __ ] your eyes oh
yeah oh thank you man
oh yeah let me see them flash man now I
don't know if they had any genetic
problems like I said it actually does
seem like the media and everything I've
kind of stayed out of their business
which is kind of cool
I don't know because I know because
inbreeding does cause like genetic
difficulties but sometimes it takes a
few generations so they might have
turned out okay but like I said because
of them being confined for so long and
not having you know not seeing the Sun
until they were adults have caused them
some real problems but they do seem to
be you know working through it and
they're in care and everything like that
so hopefully everything works out well
for them also there was um this is weird
too I don't even think about this but
when they they tried to like reintroduce
the upstairs children and the downstairs
children because like I said three of
them were taken out and raised in the
normal house and they had to get over
there was like a like a lot of
psychological issues between those two
as well because like the the downstairs
children were very resentful of the ones
that have been taken away and the
upstairs children had really really bad
guilts like once they found out because
they didn't know they were too little
when they were taken out like a horror
movie yeah and what and once they found
out that those kids were that their
siblings were down there they felt
[ __ ] horrible about it and it took
them like a really long time to work
through that um actually the rape of
that movie room not the room not tommy
wise oh but the movie room with brie
Larson was it wasn't I think it was
loosely based on this case and another
one that's kind of similar to it like
you know what I mean with somebody like
keeping somebody in a [ __ ] bunker for
although I don't think in the movie I
don't think it was her dad I think it
was just like some stranger person but
uh yeah this was like the dad case this
is like completely [ __ ] up um so I
don't know like I said I don't know if
Josef Fritzl is still alive I think he
might be he actually did change his name
in 2017 um he actually somebody in the
prison did beat his ass so that's good
he got a bunch of his teeth knocked out
so whoever did that hero need to be
buckled yeah I don't know non-consensual
man-on-man action in the prison sexual
retribution the thing that kills me
about it and you kind of saw some it is
a race if you're a rapist you're on the
[ __ ] menu in prison and like I said
the [ __ ] that happens and it seems like
they're the first ones to cry when they
have the same get it done back to them
they're like I was just taking [ __ ] why
are you taking my boy puss in and then
they thought yeah
with [ __ ] you thank you yeah like did
you ever think that maybe that would be
turned around on you yes
like there's somebody else you didn't
say why I see how you are and you didn't
think that sometimes people might do
that [ __ ] on purpose no like oh you
three people how [ __ ] fail
[ __ ] yeah you don't like it yeah
dude got big [ __ ] reputation points
for [ __ ] getting you up in your
[ __ ] little [ __ ] [ __ ] you know I'm
talking about [ __ ] then he's
grandstanding in front of the other
inmates I got him I got him that's how
they do well yeah and like I said in
this case you know I'm just not gonna
feel bad about it if somebody thought
and in fact I'm kind of happy that
somebody just punched him in the face
and knocked all those teeth out good fun
lucky he didn't end up with a
[ __ ] walking walking him down
the middle of the tier arm and arm
sporting him on his arm like a
cheerleader you know talking about just
to show him off you know yeah yeah he
was in everything like Netflix there was
a period in like British cinema history
where that dude was yeah like he was in
everything he's lucky he didn't end up a
[ __ ] prison shirt trophy wife he's
too ugly for that yeah when even even in
the prison population I feel like this
is a way like a step too far you know
what I mean I think so because dudes in
prison they have daughters too
yeah well I think I think somebody would
have gone after him just for the clout
yeah that's a good look look at the look
look what I did
and look how light and it was a hugely
famous good not just in Austria but all
over the world in fact I think like the
Australian get the Austrian government
rather I think they kind of felt like
the need to come out and apologize like
sorry this happen or a country it's
really a national it was a special to me
I mean you know everybody's not like
that we that's right
look somebody mention it do I hear
fleece Johnson is needed you're right
here's tryla fleece Johnson was needed
you guys know who flees Johnson is just
cool like a fleece Johnson from our own
[ __ ] YouTube you'll see also known as
aka the bootie warrior he's a legendary
prison figure here and you know it's
he knows what he is he knows what he is
no shame in his game no shame in his
game all right so do you want to talk
about the Elizabeth Smart case now
yeah you read this yeah this will be the
last one do you need to do anything you
do I'm good yeah I think I'm good I'm
still on my first drink you're like
almost done with your second one I might
refill it in a while but you can go
ahead well why don't you wait and then
you can refill mine at the single time
they're gonna miss we only have we only
ample Tom and viagra I don't know I
don't know what you mean by that you
have an erection lasting more than four
hours yeah viagra cialis
I need to get more of that that [ __ ]
there man you just [ __ ] it was a
recreational drug all right so we're
gonna silver coffin I'm entered Lake man
yeah yeah bee's nest was saying it's
kind of like a literate Leonard Lake
project Miranda similar yeah those guys
were [ __ ] nastier though they were
killing as much I need to go back and
really because we did a show on this
[ __ ] I mean all these dudes like
[ __ ] pissed me off and grossed me out
but it's like I know some of important
than others I guess
mm-hmm yeah author of the book said that
he was inspired by the case okay yeah
cuz I think there was another case too
it might have been that JC that JC
Duggar we need to call in show yeah you
guys can like talk to us on the show
this is good that I kind of like that
all right so let's talk about Elizabeth
Smart you came in now this happened in
2002 in Salt Lake City Utah
yeah remember this case now Alyssa is
smart at the time she was 14 years old
14 and Q is a bug she has
her family was Mormon she was actually
she was a very sweet girl very good
student she played the harp um you know
just a regular girl did cross country
everything like that so one night she
was lying in her bed she had a little
sister named Mary Katherine who was nine
at the time and they like they had a big
bed in their room and they shared a bed
and like what they would do is they you
know they would go to bed and Elizabeth
would read to her little sister and then
they would go to sleep so on this
particular night though they both go to
sleep and then Elizabeth wakes up and
there is a dude in the room holding a
knife to her throat basically saying
come with me or I'm gonna kill you and
your whole family and Mary Katherine the
nine year old she woke up and she kind
of saw what was going on but she was one
she was too scared to see anything and
two she was afraid that if she said
something or alerted the dude that she
was awake that maybe the dude would kill
her or maybe and then maybe that the
parents wouldn't know where Elizabeth
had gone so she like pretended she was
asleep and just kind of like watched
what happened so she would be able to
tell everybody here's the shame about
this kind of [ __ ] all right
this dude made this [ __ ] threat to
this little girl and I could understand
from her point of view this probably
looked like a real threat but if you
were to actually look at this guy you
know push it from my point of view I'd
cut through this [ __ ] like a hot
knife through butter all right this guy
was leaning I'll [ __ ] him [ __ ] all
right and I doubt he could have taken
her dad she should have just [ __ ]
screamed out there's just nothing to
this guy just a [ __ ] wait you don't
know I mean like a little girl she's
scared I mean I'd be scared if you woke
up in the middle of night and some
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'll reach out real
quick just grab those biceps if I you
feeling awesome you're good
work on that boat [ __ ] I mean the thing
about it like I said you know not to
victim blame at all cuz like I said
these are little kids you're talking
about the thing is is that her dad was
probably a lot bigger than him and all
she had to do to start scream and he
wouldn't cut her he'd run but their kids
they don't [ __ ] know well yeah they're
just little they're just right yeah and
you don't really expect like somebody to
just I mean because nobody heard
anything yeah this dude basically so he
just comes in Holden aye dude is
basically a bum he's basically a bum
yeah all right that's what's [ __ ] up
yeah yeah and what ended up happening so
he just like takes her out of the house
and then the little sister Mary
Catherine she runs into the parents room
as soon as she's as soon as they're gone
and it's like you know Elizabeth is gone
like a guy took her and the parents
didn't believe her at first like as she
wouldn't she thought she was having a
bad dream or whatever she's like no I'm
serious like a guy took her we're not
gonna find her it's like you know she's
gone
and then so the parents start looking
all over the house like oh maybe she's
just downstairs it's fine or whatever so
they go down there but then they see
that in the kitchen
that there's like a screen like in the
window and it's cut and then they start
freaking out and then they call the cops
now as it turned out she had been
Elizabeth Smart had been taken by this
guy named Brian David Mitchell which
kind of made me laugh because my
brother's name is Brian Mitchell
although his middle name is not David
but so I was like my brother did not
kidnap anyone
so like I said these are these are all
Mormons the guy that kidnapped her was
also a Mormon although he kind of went
off on a weird like tangent later and
like kind of went off did his own thing
but the smart family were Mormons as
well as a lot of people in Salt Lake
City are um the thing about Brian mitt
oh thank you oh my goodness thank you
here happen and she was
[Laughter]
knocking tastes the [ __ ] you the [ __ ] I
like I was like different colors yeah
every time I make sure you get a shirt
dude make a shirt I know we're trying to
like I just gotta do the shirt we gotta
design today I gotta show it tre if you
like he's a subscriber right yeah well
like I said people like if I'm trying to
like make a big huge list of like
everybody that's given us like take care
everybody
things are starting to open back up I'll
get to it well I get it well I just want
everybody sizes so I can like him
because I'm gonna order the shirts from
jiffy shirts and then we can just get
him Michaels and get like scream scream
gonna make the ship yeah so so this
douche um so he also came from a Mormon
family now what he said after they
caught him was that his family he came
from like a big family like a lot of
Mormon families are he says that to
learn about sex his dad showed him like
these medical like a medical journals
all these like explicit photos of like
genitalia and stuff in there and also he
said look at this from the Wikipedia
page he says to teach him about
independence he would drive Brian to
unfamiliar parts of the city and then
leave him there and let him find his own
way home okay now this kid seemed kind
of [ __ ] up from the beginning like I
said it might have wanted is true I
don't know what's it I mean his parents
might have been [ __ ] up I don't really
know but apparently the kids started
getting in trouble when he was a
teenager he started exposing himself
um and got sent to juvie when he was 19
he married a 16 year old girl and they
had a couple of kids but the you know
the wife ended up getting them and then
after that he seemed to become like a
drifter like he joined the Harry
Krishna's for a while he was kind of an
alcoholic he had a history of drug abuse
um so so he married again he had another
wife named Debbie they had couple kids
and then she had like three kids I think
now the wife later
said that Brian was abusive which like I
said not surprising there were also
allegations that he had sexually abused
their three-year-old son let me see them
and guys don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about we're gonna have to lift
that clip out of airplane airplane one
had two black dudes ever cool this [ __ ]
[ __ ] walking off the plane going
babysitting flashbulbs better than [ __ ]
I grew up in that [ __ ]
my uncle red from Mammoth Mountain
poltergeists just say let me see them
flashbulbs all [ __ ] time we wanted
some see every time every single say
that I keep thinking that you're talking
about boobs no just appreciation like
the paparazzi or like paparazzi yeah
yeah yeah uncle red used to see it
that's pretty funny
that's just like when we first started
when we started doing this that's the
first time I ever heard you say that
yeah well it's because it comes up it
looks like a color yeah it's kind of
[Laughter]
like a seal Oh Jonah says I think our
niece would die if we could get the tea
jenny is wearing that's like her
favorite film I made this actually make
it look Dead Ringers is actually one of
my favorite asking how you get a shirt
if you're a subscriber or a patron or
patron on it it's a $20 Knut patron or
if like I've also been giving like
people that give like through PayPal and
like give like big donations like that
I'm go get you guys give it if you're
$20 a month patron you're gonna get it
you're gonna get a shirt every quarter
yeah or whatever we get whatever it
because I think we miss [ __ ] we [ __ ]
up the last one nothing is is that if
you don't give us the [ __ ] sizes
because we send out emails in the
contact people what size do you want and
a lot of people don't respond if we
don't ever get a response about what the
size we don't send it cuz a lot of
people don't give a [ __ ] but some people
do or if you give us donations you're -
I'll send you some shirts and they're
they're handmade I make them through
photo screen yeah and she does the
designs it's actually
this is that's actually this is as a
loan that's Zazzle but she made that
yeah but they're usually just one color
white on black yeah they would look like
this yeah but they have our logos and
they have different things sometimes
it's a mash-up we had a we had a Friday
the 13th one I like that one but we got
a new one come and I haven't seen it yet
she's just yeah I just I finished the
design yesterday night and I yeah but if
you guys sent us so what's a good way to
contact you email email or Facebook or
yeah quickest way is email or Facebook
because I check that like mango badger
Matt cuz Matt you got you've been good
and [ __ ] lately just contact us not make
sure you get a couple of them yeah okay
just remind me just remind us and tell
us what size you cuz I have like a big
list going and I have to give I need
like mailing address we're gonna do a
big shipment no it'll be like a while
because I got out order the shirts yeah
get all the sizes and then we got to
print them and then I gotta get off yeah
or not make him then we'll send them out
but yes we're gonna do that alright so
like I said so this guy allegedly
molested the three year old his three
own three year old son they couldn't
really find any physical evidence of
that but his you know visitation what
the kids was still you know supervised
like after they divorced now so he
divorces Debbie who's his second wife
and then he marries this other woman
Wanda bar Z who was his accomplice in
the kidnapping of Elizabeth Smart now at
the time that he married her she was 40
years old and she had six kids of her
own and her kids were apparently not a
fan of her so she was a terrible person
as well one of her kids even claimed
that she had cooked and fed her her own
pet rabbit like one of the kids said
that so that's pretty [ __ ] up so like
I said they were both Mormons but then
they started kind of going off in their
own little weird direction like you know
in their own little
Mormon sect or whatever that they were
making in their own Brian Mitchell
changed his name to Emanuel and he
basically thought or claimed that he was
a prophet and that he had visions and
that basically he was the guy that had
been chosen to get all these wives and
fight the Antichrist that was his story
and he was sticking to to combat the
Antichrist of course you need a bunch of
wives and another buddy I guess a bunch
of children and a bunch of underage that
works oh thank oh my goodness thank you
very much Haden that's awesome get some
booze oh we will don't worry about send
Jenny a private message after the show
Oh make sure you get some shirts yeah
like I said just remind me because I
have like a huge list and it's like so I
can't like right I'm trying to remember
everybody but it's like it's really
hurting I knew their buddies addresses
and stuff so yeah so he changes his name
to Emanuel his wife Wanda changes her
name to Hephzibah and they decide
they're just gonna go like on this
mission and they're just gonna like
wander around and Panhandle and try to
like spread their message of whatever
the [ __ ] the message was that he was
gonna fight the Antichrist and he needed
all these wives in show like that so
they would be seen often around downtown
Salt Lake City you know asking people
for money and [ __ ] like that and it's
weird because Bryan Mitchell he
originally looked like a real clean-cut
dude like you know like you would
imagine a Mormon would look like you
know what I mean like you have got a
short hair if you guys don't know what
Mormons are if you're another country
they have them in another country yeah
they're a little more rare though they
even haven't they even had some in
Brazil Mormons are a [ __ ] interesting
and interesting Christian cult that they
have in the United States
it's very Gnostic it has its own texts
they're not very old
they're almost they almost read like
sci-fi in a certain way but really a lot
of the old Christian texts kind of read
like sci-fi too but almost kind
a lot of elements of the borrowed from
Islam but one of the weird thinks about
Mormons is that for a while they're
practiced selective breeding they tend
to be very good-looking and pretty
healthy so that's just kind of a basic
description of a Mormon yeah this guy I
don't know like I don't know I wouldn't
personally call him good-looking but
before he went all like you know Jesus
bum um he looked like a totally
respectable
yeah like clean-cut in the upper echelon
of the [ __ ] Latter day Saints Church
her [ __ ] living models yeah I know
remember that prom picture of me yeah
that was with a [ __ ] basically a
Mormon princess oh that girls are more
but I didn't yeah her dad was almost
kind of like the equivalent to a Mormon
Bishop that was in charge of the mission
over Brazil her name was Molly day and
she was like the cutest girl in school
really I wasn't dating her but it's kind
of like you know doing the prompting had
the prom king and the prom king male
vote on who looks the best then they put
you together yeah of course the date
that I was with that night was pissed
well yeah yeah I mean but towards the
end of your senior year anyway no Molly
look like a mouth yeah and that's a
high-ranking Mormon kind of like a
high-ranking Scientologist very similar
although I feel like Scientologists
aren't quite as good-looking but yeah
they're not as they have all that thing
where Elmo never told them that smoking
was good for you Yeah right
the difference being is that Scientology
has been around for generations and of
course the high-ranking ones always had
their select pick of the best-looking
women and over a few generation attended
they stratify yeah there's a stretch
there's a genetic stratification going
on in the Mormon Church yeah yeah so
yeah so like I said the guy was kind of
clean-cut and that'll kind of come into
play later on because it would turn out
that the reason that he knew about
Elizabeth Smart was because he had been
begging like in the street and
family had given him work at their house
so he had actually worked at their house
I think it was only a day or two like he
worked on the roof and like did some
handyman [ __ ] around the house and I
guess he saw Elizabeth and decided that
she that God said that she was supposed
to be one of his wives and that's how
that worked out I mean it was a while
like you know between him being at the
house and between him kidnapping her
but yeah so he looked kind of like you
know he I don't think as far as I could
determine he didn't look like a Jesus
mom when they hired him to work at the
house he just looked like a normal dude
that was like down on his luck but like
later on as it went on he's starting to
look more and more like Jesus he'd go
random robes and he had like a big huge
beard and [ __ ] so like I said so he
breaks into their house into the smart
house um on June 5th 2002 broke in and
took Elizabeth now even though the
sister Mary Katherine she woke up she
didn't get a super good look at him but
she did give the cops a fairly okay
description she said he's about the
height of my brother which would have
been about five foot eight
she said he was 30 or 40 years old even
though he was in actual a little bit
older than that she said he was wearing
light-colored clothes even though he was
wearing black um but she said he had
dark hair and she thought he had a gun
but it was actually a knife um
she also said something very interesting
and this would actually come into play
later on even though the cops didn't
take it seriously until later she said
that his voice was familiar but she
couldn't quite place it she said it's
not like somebody I know but somebody
I've heard them talk before you know
what I mean like it wasn't a friend of
theirs or someone that was really close
to them but she knew she had heard the
voice before she just couldn't remember
where she had heard it and that would
come into play later on who we like we'd
seized up okay there we go um okay so
she also told the police that she
thought she heard the guy say that he
was taking Elizabeth for ransom
she said that he looked all right like
he seemed like he was polite he was
clean he was like nicely dressed and
everything like oh look what got the
of the Mormon princess no there is there
me a prom date
what are you tipping in from there is
this I can't really see it yeah here we
go
that was my prom picture yeah alright so
let's see alright so as I said he
kidnaps their daughter and they you know
see the windows but could open
everything like that now there was
actually I was watching earlier today
there was a Lifetime movie because you
know every time there's a crime a
lifetime makes a movie about you so of
course there was one actually I think it
was two about this one that was the I am
Elizabeth Smart which I think was based
on her book and then the one that I saw
which was the Elizabeth Smart story
which I think came out in 2015 or
something like that and in that one I'm
not sure how accurate this is but
normally in a case like this the first
you know suspects they would question
would be the parents because they have
to eliminate them and also because a lot
of times when a kid goes missing or you
know comes to harm or something like
that a lot of times you know sometimes
the parents are involved so they have to
like eliminate them as suspects so they
did kind of seem to focus on maybe they
thought that the dad or the another
family member had something to do with
it you know so that was kind of that
whole issue but you know the you know
the parents came out they were just like
they were adamant that they had nothing
to do with it they count on the media
and everything like that there were all
these like [ __ ] searches they had
[ __ ] dogs and everything like that
the sad thing about it was that Brian
Mitchell and Wanda bar Z they didn't
take her that far at least initially
they were on foot they were homeless so
basically they took her like out of her
house and like behind the house and like
over this mountain or something like
that and then took her to this [ __ ]
campsite you know and they take her to
the campsite and then he like marries
her yeah and then rapes her yeah
and NASA made yeah that's what he said
she said that's the word he yes and he's
like and I was only 14 she's like I'm
not entire she's like I can't really
remember but she's like I'm not entirely
sure I even knew what that word meant
she's like I think I kind of knew when I
was opening it wasn't that but then it
started to happen she's like oh it was
that but you know it was that kind of
thing um and also he you know like I
said they just lived in this [ __ ]
campsite out in the woods and basically
he kept her leashed to a tree like with
this metal cable like it was around her
ankle like she could go from the tree to
the tent and that's it
like to keep her from running away so
the cops are like you know they have the
bloodhounds they search the house her
fingerprints DNA everything like that
they didn't find anything now early in
the investigation they actually thought
that they had a pretty decent lead now
there was this guy named Richard Ricci
and he had worked for the smart family
as a handyman and he had worked there
for several months I believe so the
family we're all familiar with him he
knew like all the kids names and he had
been there they all knew who he was now
he had also had a heroin problem and he
had robbed or you know stolen things
from other houses in the neighborhood
and he had stolen a few things from the
smarts house in particular like some of
the mother's jewelry and some other
things like that so it seemed like
initially after the cops were kind of
over there oh the family did it kind of
thing after they figured out that the
dad and the uncle and everything like
that did everything do with it
then it seemed like they laser focused
on this Richard Ricci dude and they
didn't really want to hear any other
information you know what I mean so it
really seemed like they and I can I can
kind of see why they did that because he
did seem like a good suspect I mean he
was a handyman he had worked in the
house for a significant period of time
he needs a layout he knew all the kids
names he had stolen from that family he
had stolen from other families in the
neighborhood you know so there was every
reason to think that maybe he was
suspicious also his only alibi for the
the disappearance was his wife saying no
he was in bed with me
which is an alibi but it's not the best
alibi so I feel like the cops kind of
thought oh well this is the guy well he
like vehemently denied it
you know there's still interviews with
him like up on YouTube and everything
like that but the cops really didn't
seem to think it was him however he had
a brain hemorrhage um while he was in
while he was in custody and was
essentially brain dead so at this stage
they still thought it was him even
Elizabeth smarts parents were kind of
leaning toward it being him um but at
this point you know he you know his life
support was eventually you know
disconnected and he died so they were
kind of left in this limbo where they
thought maybe it was him but maybe not
but now he's dead so there's nothing we
can do about it and it's like it won't
be solved we don't know where Elizabeth
is he never told us and all this other
kind of [ __ ] so it seemed like after
that guy died the cops were just kind of
like I don't want to say they were just
like pawning the family off but they
were kind of like well that was who did
it and he's dead now you know maybe he
had an accomplice and we're still
looking for that but you know just like
leave us alone and bla bla bla bla so
Zab whole thing happened now it seemed
like the parents during this time you
know they were very religious and the
dad in particular was absolutely
convinced that Elizabeth was still alive
somewhere now it does seem like the mom
who I think her name is Louis it does
seem like the mom you know obviously she
wanted Elizabeth still be alive but I
think she was kind of more open to the
possibilities look it's that hardly ever
happens and so she was kind of more
willing to entertain the possibility
that her daughter might be dead so you
know just because statistically that's
wasn't gonna give up on it
so there's good though yeah well that's
what you want yeah I mean honestly dad
man
did I'd know that I know she's alive
yeah and he was just like in like he
basic is lucky that she was though cuz
most of them because most of the time
yeah and I and I feel like it's it's sad
to say but I feel like in you know 99%
of situations that would not have worked
out the way you know it looks good in
retrospect bit that he said you know I
knew she was alive the whole time but at
a few but other parents say that too and
then it turns out that their kids are
dead so you know and that's terrible and
they were just like really lucky that it
worked out in this situation even though
you know she Elizabeth obviously with
her a horrible ordeal over the time she
was gone yeah smart was a good girl was
[ __ ] bad I'm glad that she came
through it alright yeah she was cute as
a bug yeah she's done a TED talk and
ever seen ham being do with this it was
just [ __ ] thrust upon her by some
[ __ ] nutcase
yes I'm dude just broke into her but he
had worked at their house like he was a
homeless guy
the family had felt bad for him he had
asked them for money or work or
something and they said hey you know
maybe there's something around our house
you can do and we'll give you some money
so he came to their house like one day
or something worked on the roof and I
guess he saw Elizabeth and decided that
she was gonna be his wife and he just
planned it over this [ __ ] time period
just busted into their house and just
took her yeah in the middle of the night
and basically took her all over the lake
all over Salt Lake City and the scary
thing about this too was that him and
his wife Wanda they you know they would
Panhandle in downtown Salt Lake City and
she was an Elizabeth there was with them
but he would make the women wear like
you know he put robes on put like veils
over their faces and stuff and then he
would say that oh it's you know against
our religion like to take the veil off
so you can't see their faces so no one
really thought and it's scary because
like a couple of times when they were in
like a diner or a library or something
like that like somebody would see the
girl and would get suspicious like they
would look at her eyes and be like man
that looks like you know what I mean but
the fact that
and a lot of people have kind of gone
into this too because it did seem like I
don't really want to say it like this
but I can't think of another way to say
it it does seem like there was a lot of
opportunities for Elizabeth to get away
and she didn't but like I said she was
one she was scared she was 14 - um
Brian had told her that he had other
followers and that if she tried to get
away that he would kill her family or he
would have some of his followers kill
her family and I don't think she had any
reason to doubt that also he had another
woman with him who you know when
somebody came up like asking and them
questions like the woman would like grab
her wrists like that and be like or he
would grab her like under the table and
be like you better not say anything or
bad shits gonna happen um so she was
afraid of him and I think she did try to
like do little things like to try and
escape and [ __ ] like that but the shitty
thing is that a day or two after she was
taken and they were just like out in
this [ __ ] camp like out in the woods
and the search parties that were looking
for her like they almost found her they
were like kind of like close by so close
that she could hear someone calling her
and she recognized the voice it was her
uncle's yeah and yeah and it was like
right there well you chalk it all up to
youth - yeah I mean yeah they're
impressed with adults they believe what
adults yeah and she was a little [ __ ]
okay and she was a little bit sheltered
you come from like a very religious like
kind of I mean you can have you had she
had she been a little bit older she
realized that this dude's full of [ __ ]
yeah I mean she could've really just
kind of had an outburst in public and
grab somebody give me where these people
they abducted me and it would have been
the end of it yeah but you know you when
you're a little kid you believe well
I'll have your family killed you know
well yeah you don't know well if you're
a kid you don't know so that's me tells
me that you yes somebody tells now that
voice you want a submission hold [ __ ]
turn your neck too far I'm gonna hear it
crack oh yeah you're 14 you're 14 you're
gonna believe this [ __ ] but to me he's
just a bum yeah you know a stop
through you yeah in front of your woman
okay but I didn't understand you know
when you're a little kid you're a little
girl and you're half his weight you
might actually believe these threats and
he's raped her numerous times he beats
her numerous times it's like he's made
all kinds of threats I had that [ __ ]
calling me daddy within about five
minutes apparently also she said later
that he had you know would force her to
take drugs drink alcohol he would feed
her garbage
um he basically I don't know if he
necessarily brainwashed her all the way
but he did he made her change her name
no she changed it to ester and he
basically they just wandered around him
and this woman and they dragged her
around everywhere saying how you know
we're protecting you from the sins of
the world you know God said this is what
we're supposed to do and so it was just
like this whole thing and I think she
was like a unit she was scared of them
yeah he's lucky because with me he'd be
face to face with [ __ ] Satan and he
could read that Bible all he wanted and
it's not gonna be same break his [ __ ]
bone his wife is gonna be pleading and
[ __ ]
then I'll [ __ ] her up to set her in her
place and then go back I'll work on him
I don't have I don't like to have you
know I wouldn't never I'm glad that
there's law enforcement all this [ __ ]
that's going on now just ban police and
[ __ ] like that
I think oh that's just ridiculous
because that means I'm in charge when
I'm in charge that's like putting the
[ __ ] devil in charge and there's
millions of them like me you know I mean
it's good that we have reasonable
level-headed people because I'm not one
of them if I got it if I got a hold that
[ __ ] man it would they'd make a
hole they'd make a whole goddamn Quentin
Tarantino movie behind what I did well
like I said I don't think but see that's
a very natural yeah
inclination very natural because this
guy is this guy is terrible a [ __ ]
terrible I mean and that's like a normal
thing
I want a name where do you tape it on
the phone and get a recordings of
everything to [ __ ] make a whole
online monument to this man's suffering
well like I said I think the main thing
about it is that because you do some
[ __ ] like that to the to it innocent yes
and like I said what you know it's just
like we were talking about Ariel Castro
about the [ __ ] case it's like these
people are very willing to make other
people suffer yeah but then then they
want to be a [ __ ] win it but then if
they don't want these are their answer
when it's their time they can dish it
but they can't take it out race is
something that even this goes back to
the [ __ ] samurais [ __ ] you know I
mean with [ __ ] hagakure and [ __ ] like
that and those books where you just
don't have a right to take a human life
or to [ __ ] make another person suffer
unless you are also willing to give up
your own life and to suffer drama I
don't understand that [ __ ] how can these
dudes want to jump in this game where
they do this but they want to be immune
to the game it's just it's it's not it's
in consumed I think that's what makes
people think when I joined the army I
knew that I could be killed
yeah I just that was just part of the
[ __ ] deal yeah I mean that's
something you have to you have to
internalize it and [ __ ] actualize it
that this is a [ __ ] game in which you
can win or lose you know what I mean I
don't understand this thing where it's
like solipsism you know I mean where
you're the center of the universe and
you can do whatever you want but another
person's will oh you're immune to that
this is a photo like that concept I
think that's the problem and I think
that a lot of people like that serial
killers and all these type of like
people with this type of psycho
solipsism yeah yeah it's basically you
think you can do whatever you want but
you get upset when other people do it
they will exercise their will are their
right they don't like that yeah because
it surprises them because I feel like
people like that think everyone else is
essentially at MPC yeah exactly
they think and she went so when they see
somebody acting like in a way that's
like not what they expect or not what
they want it upsets them because they
expect everyone to just kind of do what
yes yeah yeah
infuriates me yeah no one has rights but
me exactly yes like somebody grabs
Pookie and starts doing [ __ ]
oh you think you're gonna be immune you
think you're gonna be immune no I'm
gonna do some [ __ ] to you
worse just you know I'm gonna do
something worse to you because I'm like
I get me I get at them first there's
anything left then you can I'm into that
Old Testament [ __ ] you know I mean
avenged what you do you're I am you know
I will avenge Sevenfold and then 77 to
that [ __ ] I can understand that [ __ ] I
understand it very well that's why I
would make a good Italian mobster I
understand exactly yes I would make a
great Italian but like I said that's a
very natural yeah thing like if somebody
did some I love the Italians I got
Italians out there I understand it it
goes all the way back to ancient Rome
Masters of good and evil yeah I
understand to achieve you know because
life is not good versus evil it's mostly
evil versus evil but you can use evil
versus evil to achieve a greater good
does that there's a way I'm just saying
if you're terrible you deserved out
terrible shut up yeah of course and like
I said anybody that has a kid and I
don't have a kid but I have Pookie and
she's like my kid and like I said if
anybody did anything pokey
yeah this is the end of you that was
like a no no that's like a child she is
like a child exactly and like I said and
I'm not gonna make it easy for you
either I'm just gonna like I'm gonna cut
off little bits of you and I'm gonna eat
them in front of your face and
everything I'm gonna I'll think about it
a long time but yeah so so like I said
so they so they've been wandering around
for a little while as made her change
her name they you know she has to wear
like all these [ __ ] veils and
everything they decide that they're
gonna like I guess the Heat's getting
too much in Salt Lake City like people
are starting because they the dumb thing
about this I don't know like if this
dude is really crazy if he thinks God's
gonna protect him or something like that
but he's not a master criminal let's
just put it that way because I mean he
stayed in Salt Lake City the
panhandling outside like in downtown
Salt Lake City and even though Elizabeth
is wearing a veil and like she you know
she with the hood and everything like
that
they look so weird that people are gonna
notice them and like a lot of people
notice them I mean they even had like
nicknames around downtown you know like
oh there's the Jesus because there's
Jesus or there's this that the other
thing because they looked unusual so
they stood out so my tab was going die
how much time we got left on this show
not much so much just you know you're
alright just let me finish on this I
meant I can plug it in if I have to well
yeah you got a charge or something we go
get the charger cable win all right
all right so I'm gonna keep on talking
about this case so they decide that
they're going to move somewhere but they
don't know where and I guess you know
they're homeless and they don't have you
know phones or anything plus it's only
2002 so they go into a public library
and they start looking at maps like to
decide where they're gonna move to now
while they're in this library
you know Brian's looking at maps and
they decide they're gonna go to San
Diego but while they're in the library a
cop comes in there and he gets
suspicious about because he notices them
cuz they're dressed weird and then he's
like looking at the girl and he thinks
she looks like Elizabeth Smart but he
asks her and she won't answer and then
the then Brian comes over and so it's no
that's my daughter Augustine this is my
wife and my daughter and in our religion
like women aren't allowed to talk in
public and all this other kind of [ __ ]
so the cop was just kind of like looking
at him and then he was like um I guess
okay now like later on Elizabeth said
that she was really mad at herself for
not saying anything when the cop was
right there like when the cop walked out
she was like super bummed out but like I
said they went other places they went to
grocery stores they went to restaurants
and all this other kind of [ __ ] they
even went to like this party and they
even had their picture taken like with
the veils on but no one really like a
couple people were like that's really
weird
no one really you know said anything
about it I guess so
in September of 2002 they went to San
Diego and they camped out like in this
[ __ ] creek bed and so over the next
few months they kept moving around to
these different camps and they would
sometimes like move in the middle of the
night like so they didn't get caught and
everything now for a time Brian I
believe spent at least it might have
been five to seven days in jail they
caught him stealing stuff from a church
like I'm not sure what he took like in
the movie that I watch it looked like he
just looks like some candles and like
some [ __ ] and you know plates or
something I don't know what he was
looking for he needed some more
logistical supplies I guess so he broke
into a church and like took some [ __ ]
but and he was gone for a little while
but I guess like Elizabeth and Wanda
were like still at the camp and they
didn't leave like they just kind of
stayed there so about a month after that
while the cops were still kind of not
exactly really investigating it all that
stringently and like I said they were
still convinced that Richard Rishi was
the guy and he was dead and as far as
they were concerned it's like yeah we're
sold the case is still open we're still
looking for her we're still looking for
a possible accomplice but you know the
main guy who we think it was is probably
dead so it's fine however in October of
2002 Mary Katherine suddenly remembered
where she had heard the voice before
because as I mentioned she told her
parents and she told the police that the
person that had kidnapped Elizabeth she
recognized his voice but she couldn't
place it so she came in and she told her
mom and dad she's like I think I know
whose voice that was it was Emmanuel now
as soon as she said this you know the
dad was like he couldn't believe that
she remembered because um somebody says
I might have missed it did he sexually
abuse her yes he did oh yeah yes
he was using it up yeah he I'm honestly
amazed that she didn't get pregnant you
know what I mean yeah he raped her
multiple times yeah it was pretty
horrible so so the little sister finally
remembers because there was a thing
where the cops were telling it's like
look if she was the witness she saw the
guy she heard the guy it's like don't
taint her memories so like don't talk
too much or maybe she'll remember in her
own time but it took her a little while
but she actually did remember she came
to her dad and said it was a manual now
the dad was like freaked out because
he's like dude that guy was only here
for like one day and it was a long time
ago because at this point the dad he was
starting to think like look Richard
Ricci even though he seemed a likely
suspect he's like look he doesn't sound
like the person that my daughter saw in
the room that night he's like one that
dude was really tall like if you
remember Mary Katherine said the guy
that took Elizabeth was only five at
seven five foot eight whereas Richard
Ricci was more like six foot two or
something like that he said and he also
pointed out he's like look Richard Ricci
was working in our house for like
several months and all the kids knew him
if it had been him in the room that
night Mary Katherine would have said oh
it was Richard because she knew him so
the fact that she didn't recognize the
dude but she kind of recognized the
voice she's like that made sense because
it was like this is a guy that just was
here one day and did some work but she
still she remembered what his voice
sounded like but it took her like
several months to remember you want a
drink yes okay be - bartender me well
you make better ones than make it's like
really strong one so at first the cops
were kind of like okay well that doesn't
really help us like Emmanuel we don't
know anybody with that name and it
didn't help either that in the time
period between when he had been hired at
the house and when he took her like he
looked completely different because like
I said he was real
clean-cut looking and then later he's
looked like Jesus he and looked like
kind of like a bum
so he had like you know a long beard and
everything so they had a sketch drawn
which kind of
looked pretty good it actually does kind
of look like him
now the cops that was kind of it was
kind of like a conflict because the cops
were like man don't tell the public or
don't tell the media that about this guy
because we're pretty sure it's this
other dude and it seems like the cops
were fighting with them about it and the
dad kind of went back and forth with the
cops and he was on America's Most Wanted
and he was like the guy on America's
Most Wanted um John Walsh or whoever he
was kind of like you know the cops don't
really seem like they have your best
interests at heart maybe you should just
announce this go around them and just
announce this to the this information to
the media like about Emanuel and we'll
just go directly to the public we'll go
directly to the media because the cops
don't really seem interested in helping
you at this point now I'm not sure how
this worked out because I never got the
impression from all the [ __ ] that I've
read about this case that John Walsh on
America's Most Wanted in the movie that
they may like the Lifetime movie they
dramatized it where Elizabeth's dad told
John Walsh like in confidence like when
they weren't on camera I told him about
the Emanuel leaden oh hey my daughter
remembered the voice and then later John
Walsh went on camera and said it when
the dad hadn't told him that he could do
that but from everything that I've read
about the case it seemed like that was
like an agreement thank you
that was like an agreement between them
that they were just gonna go on TV and
give this information to the public
directly instead of going through the
cops because the cops didn't really seem
to be taking it seriously either because
they thought the girl was 9 and she
didn't know what she was talking about
or because they were convinced that that
Ricci was the kidnapper or for whatever
reasons they just didn't kind of want to
hear it so basically the smart family
just went right to the public and they
said look we're looking for this dude
named Emanuel and this is kind of what
he looks like and you know he worked
here for whatever he was like a homeless
person whatever so it turned out that
March 12th 2003 or actually actually
when they showed on America's Most
Wanted they talked about the Emmanuel
thing one of Brian's Brian aka Manuel's
relatives who called in and gave cops
pictures of him so I think it was his
ex-wife like called and said that looks
like my scumbag ex-husband like whose
name is Brian Mitchell so then the cops
like had his name March 12 2003 someone
spotted Brian Mitchell with a woman and
a girl in Sandy Utah
now the he was seen by two separate sets
of people and both of these people
recognized him because they'd seen the
picture on the news at this point and
they determined the woman was Wanda
Varzi and Elizabeth at this point I
think she was just wearing the veil but
she also had like a really ridiculous
and obvious like gray wig on and a big
thing and a big pair of sunglasses so it
looked like old cheese yeah it looked
like ridiculous so a lot of people like
noticed it which like I said this dude
was not like a master criminal or
anything so a couple of people
recognized him and called the cops so
then the cops come and initially they
come up to them in a park and they're
talking to all of them initially
Elizabeth Smart said that her name was
she either said it was Esther she said
it was Augustin and she said they were
from Miami and the cops were pretty sure
at this point that it was Elizabeth so
they kept asking her what part of Miami
are you from what part of this and that
the other what I got the drinks [ __ ]
up look at that
what'd you do this is vodka and lemonade
oh that is tequila tequila sunrise well
you drink that yeah yeah Baca limited
I'm not drinking it I was gonna say
that's not my glass yeah okay I got the
I got the juices backwards that's all
right that's okay still good yeah let me
it's good yeah so yeah the cop at this
point was pretty sure that this was so
he kept like he's like what's your name
what's your name what's her name is she
kept giving him the fake name Jana is
Jana caught that
she's like that drink is too big yeah
yeah because you have that big I just
have the regular jar yes I got tequila
sunrise yeah right and then finally the
cop got her to admit that she was
Elizabeth Smart at which point they
arrested the two [ __ ] and they took
Elizabeth into the police station and I
have to admit lifetime movies are super
cheesy and everything like that but the
one I was watching about this when they
did the scene about the dad like walking
into the cop into the police station and
seeing her sitting there and then like
hugging it was that kind of teared up a
little bit it was like kind of cool and
when and you know what I mean I'm when
they interviewed like the actual couple
and there was because like I said this
is something that never happens your kid
gets kidnapped she was gone for nine
months by the way um and was raped
numerous times was dragged all over and
you know said she was being taken away
from the sins of the world no this other
kind of crap and all these horrible
things that she went through and was
finally returned to her family now there
was a long I don't want to go too much
into it like if you can go into the like
Wikipedia page and everything but that
gives a lot more into it but so Brian
Mitchell when he was taken into custody
there was this big it took eight years
for one thing like after he got arrested
for him to go to trial it was like eight
years between the arrest in the trial
because for all this time they were
trying to determine if he was mentally
competent to stand trial because one
thing that he was doing they were trying
to determine whether because I guess if
you're like come up with all these weird
religious like all this religious [ __ ]
that he was coming up with there's a
fine line between just having like
religious conviction and being
completely [ __ ] delusional and so
they were trying to like determine where
that line was and they were also trying
to determine if he was faking it because
it seemed to me I don't know Elizabeth
smart I don't know she said this
outright but she seemed to be implying
that she thought he was probably faking
it because she said he was very smart
and that he was very manipulative and it
seemed like something that he would do
that he would try to make himself
seemed crazy in court so that he
wouldn't get tried or he wouldn't get in
trouble like he would do [ __ ] like you
know he'd be brought into court and as
soon as he gets brought into court he
just starts singing hymns like at the
top of his voice so he gets removed um
you know just doing crazy [ __ ] and like
saying crazy [ __ ] to the judges and then
this so there was like a whole thing
whether he was competent strength to
stand trial
and then it was like well can we legally
medicate him against his will to make
him competent to stand trial so that was
a whole other can of worms in the end
like I said it took eight years I don't
think he went to trial till 2010 but
they actually did finally decide that he
was competent and he was found guilty
now Wanda bar Z I believe she got
fifteen years she might have been
released though at this point I can't
remember
[ __ ] is crazy I don't think so either I
think he was he just wanted some young
trim yeah oh and I forgot to mention too
this is also very special is that he um
he wasn't Elizabeth Smart wasn't the
only wife that he wanted he was also
going to make a wife out of Elizabeth's
cousin I think the cousin was named
Olivia okay I think and he actually
tried to break into their house too and
but the little girl woke up and saw him
and started screaming her head off
who was she um I think she was around
the same age nice image yeah she started
screaming her head off and he took off
told you he would take off yeah
and he took off like when she saw him
now that was another thing because when
that happened I believe like Richard
Ricci the first guy that they thought
did it was still in custody at that
point so the cops thought it was a
copycat but the dad Elizabeth smarts dad
was like that's the same dude that did
that because he was trying to take the
cousin as well scuzzbag yeah so so that
happened as well so she might have been
kidnapped also he needed his ass beat
yeah unfortunately I don't think
anyone's beat his ass yet so it's not
too late yeah somebody can still get
just more of a poor bum version and that
other dude who ran a dam the Mormon
Church who was the dude that was raping
all the little ol little kids on little
boys Warren Jeffs Oh or any was his name
Warren Jeffs I don't like that [ __ ]
he had a whole cult and they were what
they call a separatist cult yeah oh [ __ ]
let me see little thank you and it's
yours I'm buzzed yeah yeah it's Saturday
night
Matt's been contributing can't even talk
that's been dishing it out like a high
roller do this pimping you're cracking
me up with your leg [ __ ] like your
old man like yeah I'm being old man
right now are you fellow turkey necks
right now sorry they put turkey necks in
my heart
[Laughter]
he's bullet Turkey and eggs and you
didn't believe him
you guys don't know that story
it was a better heat over a year ago is
a couple years ago I had to fly back to
Mississippi because my dad was getting
like a [ __ ] quadruple bypass and
after he came out of surgery he was
telling me he goes I saw a diagram he
put some turkey necks in my mouth in
there that's a turkey Nexus yeah turkey
Mac's [ __ ] four days ago did he put
Turkey here's a salad it's like why did
he have a turkey necks and as I don't
know so I put him in now because we're
that his heart was repaired with turkey
neck skin yeah but what it really was is
that the woman lived a lot live across
the street I forgot her name she was a
sweet black woman and
she used to bring and she's young she's
about my age
well I she's younger than me in her 40s
and she feeds my dad her husband is the
[ __ ] ex-army guy so you know we're
all service people so they take care of
my dad my dad is the last white man in
Heidelberg Mississippi yes that's a
little town of about a thousand people
he's the last white guy yeah all the
rest of my died they all died off but
she brings she would bring him turkey
necks yeah and he [ __ ] loved those
turkey necks well she came and visited
him in the hospital that day yeah and
somehow it made a connection to where he
thought of Turkey he thought that the
doctor put turkey necks in it and I
think I would try to think that her name
was Glenda and ice and I was like no man
no the dead that didn't happen did he's
like there might have been turkey in
your bed reenacting man I said no I
didn't know the neighbor came visited
you yeah and she brings she makes you
turkey necks like he just couldn't
accept it I thought at the hospital he
was at before he thought that he had
been abducted by a cult that he wasn't
supposed to be in the hospital yeah and
behind my back when he was in this new
hospital that where I was you know after
I'd gotten down there his friend Sonny
okay and his friend Sonny is big into
guns and 45s he could take a 1911 and
[ __ ] just do a trigger job on it by
hand with a [ __ ] file and this dude's
a [ __ ] master pistol shot with
[ __ ] 45 he's in his 70s now but that
[ __ ] was always bad by the [ __ ]
19:11 45 and either Sonny go hit my gun
he's like what you want that for Ross
and he does we're getting out of here he
was dead serious old man escape yeah old
man inner sadness planning an escape
from the [ __ ] ICU ducted and you're
doing some kind of experiment on her go
down in my truck and get my gun
is what's gonna do it you gun loss you
just we don't get out of here okay I'm
gonna he's humoring him I'm gonna get
him yeah [ __ ] he wouldn't tell my dad
was plain enough he didn't trust me he
didn't tell me they're not
he thought I was in with him oh
afterwards if you didn't tell you that
yeah afterwards Sonny was like you know
he wanted to escape I want me to go get
his gun and the truck wasn't there the
truck was back in heidelberg parking lot
he didn't drive himself to them my dad's
gun wasn't the gun that he was talking
about was a stainless steel Walther PPK
that he had my dad bought a Walther PPK
he that's just he's been a [ __ ]
shooter his whole [ __ ] life but he
was gonna James Bond his ass out of the
[ __ ] hospital I would have laid his
heart
[ __ ] freshly put back together with
his buddy Sonny full of Turkey there
like 73 with turkey necks gonna fight
their way out through the [ __ ]
because he had been abducted by a cult
that was doing a dam experiment on his
heart his [ __ ] bizarre needs to be a
graphic yeah I feel like yeah and after
I called him there you know I was
calling I call him you know in a column
and it took him a long time to process
that you know where was I went on to
have did you
I thought they had captured me you know
his memory was all [ __ ] up that's
crazy and I was like yeah you were
trying to escape yeah I was trying to
escape you were there weren't you to say
yeah I visited you he didn't really even
remember you being there for two weeks
yeah he didn't really remember you were
in Mississippi for two weeks the doctor
said he had what was called Hospital
psychosis that he had had a psychotic
break from folk from the [ __ ]
physical trauma and the mental trauma
I can imagine he'd had all those heart
attacks and they can't [ __ ] shocking
him back to life with those [ __ ] yeah
attles well yeah that's gonna do enough
yes and I'm and and I asked him I said
dad you see any light because I had a
near-death experience in there in a
motorcycle wreck he knew about us a dad
when they shocked you when you when you
had that heart attack did you see
yourself from above did you see you see
the [ __ ] towel that's all
he's like yeah so he and he was a
Christian but he is not a Christian
anymore okay yeah he's like [ __ ] they
liked I can't even imagine like I've
only been I've only had surgery one time
and gone under anesthetic one time and
that was weird enough so I can't imagine
going through the kind of trauma that
your dad went through and like what a
number that would do on your [ __ ]
brain and it's like it wasn't even that
bad like with me it's like I just kind
of like did a lot of [ __ ] without like
talked without remembering it and like
how weird dreams about it but they're
asking turkey what turkey neck turkey
necks yeah in the South you explain this
to you I don't even eat these and I'm
southern and I love Turkey I'll eat
pretty much every part of the turkey I
don't Southern people black people to
the southern food real southern food is
black people food it's soul food yeah
and you know I grew up with it you're
not I mean hushpuppies and [ __ ] yes
bread corn bread
yeah collard greens and [ __ ] grits
and gravy and red-eye gravy and [ __ ]
all turkey necks and what you do is you
you take now I don't want to here's
something here's a [ __ ] big
misconception from people that are
[ __ ] up north they think southerners
are poor but in a way they're very rich
you have lots of space and and they eat
a lot okay food is plentiful and they
eat everything and lots of everything
and it's very good tasting food food is
a religion in the south and it's very
unhealthy lots of fun
bacon grease and and lots of [ __ ]
butter yeah
and lots of [ __ ] you know everything
salted and carbs carbs and everything's
of rice and everything's [ __ ] pasta
and macaroni lots and lots of [ __ ]
meat wild game and just like that's
somewhere we all have the diabetes they
all have what they call the diabetes of
the sugar gallons and gallons and
gallons of sweet tea all right which is
like syrup sweet we're not talking about
like soda or like that it's like it's
gonna be in the cookbook even that's a
little sweet right and one of the things
that a southerner can do is take a piece
of meat that's not worth anything and
just make that [ __ ] [ __ ] just
delicious as [ __ ] and it comes from
[ __ ] black southerners man black
southerners could take something that
really would really want anything
special and make a [ __ ] fantastic
meal out of it they taught white
southerners how to cook really deep
frying is an African thing yeah and it
and and a lot of it has to do with
deep-fried and one of the dishes that
you're gonna have the South is turkey
necks because you can buy a big [ __ ]
thing of turkey necks with the skin on
it for [ __ ] two dollars yes nobody
wants and it's for less pieces but you
can spice them and cook them right
they're just [ __ ] delicious and like
a chicken wing yeah chicken wings are
southern but originally a chicken wing
wasn't worth anything now a chicken wing
is per pound worth a lot well [ __ ] man
now they have whole entire restaurant
franchises based on yeah I first saw
chicken wings in the south you know I
mean and they weren't buffalo chicken
wing so they were just [ __ ] frying
chicken wings lots of them and eat them
with honey and [ __ ] like that and you
can get chicken wings for probably like
39 cents a pound so you just can't beat
that and you can just like Nene yeah
even a pile of [ __ ] yeah Yankees
won't eat a [ __ ] chicken wing not
back in the 70s there was some 70 [ __ ]
well now they will now they will you
know this is special and then you have
all the [ __ ] you know Paul Prudhomme
Paul Prudhomme [ __ ] Louisiana Cajun
food which just started off [ __ ] as
nothing and there's
and things in [ __ ] you don't want to
eat [ __ ] Louisiana like don't for one
second unless you got some serious
[ __ ] truck nuts
don't [ __ ] with Buddha okay we're in the
middle of a [ __ ] show you guys wanna
hear about boudin one time I was going
through I was going to the club going to
the French Quarter place called the
convent it was a [ __ ] goth club my
first wife was waiting for me down there
this is before I married her I was gonna
go you know her name was Tiffany she
look like a cross between cross between
Lily monster I'll be sure picture over
she look like
Deborah Harry anyway I was on my way
down there and go to go meet her this is
before I was even really seriously
dating were dating her living with her
and I stopped out the gas station got
some boudin and a boo there was a fried
ball of all kinds of [ __ ] net if
[ __ ] internal organs and stuff like
[ __ ] yeah it tasted okay and I ate
that boudin ball there's something like
a dollar at the gas station made it
about two miles south the freeway going
to New Orleans and all of a sudden just
open the door just threw up yeah I'm
going to show you guys I'm going to show
you guys my first wife okay I forgot
what she look like it's been such a long
time
my first way he has a type as you can
see I was just gonna say remember how
what we were talking about um
what you call it we were talking about
southern food hmm the last Gordon Ramsay
uncharted he did one in Louisiana yeah
and they were oh that's you'd mess it up
mist it up here we go what the hell
you're [ __ ] up okay but they were and
he was eating they made him shoot a
nutria which you know it's like a big
giant rat and he I thought he was gonna
make something out of it but he
chickened out but he did eat like a stew
that the dude's mom had made like out of
him and and he said it was good although
he says that if nutria is [ __ ] like
rabbit they look kind of like he kept
saying this rat which they do have rat
tails but they look more like beavers
they're invasive species so there's like
a six-dollar like if you kill them and
bring their tails in you get six dollars
per tail so some apparently some people
that live in the Bayou like that's that
their whole livelihood is they just go
around shooting all these animals and
then like collecting the bounty on him
and I guess because like I said they
don't like to waste on anything they
make stew out of the meat and it's
apparently pretty good if it's you know
yeah if it's done correctly why did I
like get all weird it looked like it got
brighter in here mmm you must have
messed it up now me I missing it for
[ __ ] around [ __ ] yeah they're saying
you print here Jimmy
huh they're saying you prettier Judy's
that's gone yeah thank you
yeah TIFF he kind of kind of looked like
he was produced Morrison a little bit
you know Vidya yeah yeah she didn't
mention that
she crazy though she's crazy though
we're all crazy yeah isn't that isn't
that what dude say yes all women are
crazy she's not goth anymore a [ __ ] a
hipster she defected she defected she
acted how can you how can you not be I
don't know it's like I'm like goth in my
DNA I can't I don't know how to be any
different I was not
jeez man you know what I mean even
before I knew what that was as soon as I
was like old enough to read I was just
like scary stuff yeah just imagine like
9090 something and you're you you run
into that it was impressive back then
Tammy says women are crazy because men
make us crazy that is exactly correct
that's true that is exactly correct
men are men are crazy making creatures
yeah I'm not crazy though well no more
than any other person I I definitely
have my crazy issues but you know who
doesn't all right what else we got to
talk about I think that's it i finished
up right because like i said she
eventually like ended up getting away
and like I said she um Elizabeth Smart
she's done TED talks she's done all
she's written books she's done all kind
of [ __ ] and they've done you know
there's tons of books there's tons of
like documentaries about her case she
seems like a very lovely human being and
she really um kind of seemed to like
really get through so she gives like all
these inspirational talks now about she
said the day after she was found her mom
told her like look don't let like this
guy like took nine months of your life
that you will never get back but don't
give him one second more of your life
like thinking about him or worrying
about him or anything like it's over and
we just leaned to move forward which in
a way I thought was kind of like I don't
know in a way it sounds like you're kind
of like minimizing it but then in a way
it's kind of good too because you don't
want that [ __ ] to think about that
dude for the rest of your [ __ ] life
right like all this [ __ ] that he did
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
so he's apparently he's still in prison
dude pretty much [ __ ] I do this [ __ ] all
these dudes all these dudes need their
[ __ ] ass beat yeah all the ones of
this chef yeah I mean Ariel Castro he's
dead but we could dig him up and kick
his ass
[Laughter]
but especially I think that honestly I
think out of all these I think that
Josef Fritzl and pissed me off the most
I mean that's kind of a hard thing to
pick cuz these are all [ __ ] up but
that case just I mean that is that's
your daughter yeah another thing too is
that he had a bunch of other kids Josef
Fritzl now I think later one of the sons
came forward and said that he was
sexually molesting him as well damn um
so I don't know if he sexually molested
all of his kids that's weird and he just
decided that Elizabeth was the one he
was gonna pick that to like capture to
capture so I don't know if he was doing
that to all the kids like like I said at
least one of the male children came
forward and said that he was molesting
two which would not surprise me because
like I said this dudes like a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] so any more evidence of
his piece of [ __ ] is just of course yeah
of course all right so we've been we're
gonna close it out people I think so are
you guys gonna focus any more than Flash
well three and a half green half and
we've still got 53 people watching but
hey that was a good show like to thank
you guys is there anything else we gotta
do look we got a plug books if you guys
[ __ ] want to buy a book and go on
Ginny Ashford [ __ ] Amazon yeah and
she's got Matt Mountain poltergeist
she's got the [ __ ] three true crime
books what else you got up there Jenny I
got my horror fiction like I said I just
came up the new edition of hopeful
monsters yeah and print and ebook the
audiobook is coming it's done it's just
and it's uploaded it takes a while for
them to process for them to go through
like they're all in control yeah
when that ship processes we'll give you
guys a heads up because you might want
to eat you guys are probably don't want
to listen to her nonfiction Jenny's
nonfiction is awesome my fiction you
mean they're fiction I mean yes well my
agent Johnson it's all good thank you
again Matt thank you very much we're
gonna do oh thank you Mega badgers we're
gonna do two of these a month probably
when
yeah I kind of feel like like I said I'm
I was I don't know why I was so
reluctant to these I guess just because
I was afraid like I said I would space
out and like lose my place in my notes
which I did do a couple of times so what
we covered that up pretty good um that I
wanted it like a chance to edit it out
but now that we've started doing them I
actually I I enjoy these more because
like I said it's at least everybody
knows it's live it's like if I have to
get up in the bathroom and go to the
bathroom everybody knows that it's like
you know I can interact with people in
real time it's like I come more into
that jhana blaha saying she's reading
faces feeling - right now yeah I'm
working on the fourth one and Matt
$75.00 were the bulbs thank you you see
yes everybody loves the streams and hey
man thanks everybody and we will see you
guys once the next time we're gonna see
them we will probably honestly will
either do a matinee or sidetracks
tomorrow probably is it gonna be alive
yeah okay so we'll see you gotta have
tomorrow probably about two o'clock
we'll either doing we'll probably be a
side tracks or a movie review we'll see
two o'clock our time we'll send you guys
a notification I usually I posted I
usually post on Instagram Facebook and I
usually post it on the community tab on
YouTube as well like if we're gonna do
one that way that day I mean we'll do it
on Sunday we'll probably do one on
Monday - um maybe it may be a review
we'll see how that goes but like I said
I kind of like doing these they're fun
yeah okay then well thanks folks we'll
see you guys tomorrow yeah we'll see you
guys tomorrow remember like share
subscribe all that other kind of stuff
patreon you guys know thank you all for
stopping by and spending your Saturday
night with us we gotta finish drinking
and then wake up me hungover tomorrow
Jesus Christ I hope you sleep okay [ __ ]
it with me and Pookie killin roses to be
like look look I got one Chevy look
there's one over there look I got it
she's such a good girl yeah I just
thought I'm just happy this isn't trying
to bring it
I mean that I was worried about that
yeah that was just kind of like he'll
try to bring me a lizard well no she
brings me a lizard after she gets it
into the house she sneaks in into the
house she tried to hide the fact that
she's gosh she's like one yeah and then
you go to the living room and she's good
look I got it I got it
well as well because I've heard stories
of people that had cats and their cats
like killed like say a mouse or
something in the middle of the night and
then like the cat will jump up on the
bed and like drop the mouse like in
their hand or in their mouths or
something so I'm like kind of videus so
I'm kind of worried that Pookie was
gonna do that with the roach one day and
I was gonna like [ __ ] hear you dad
I'm just gonna throw up forever so I was
kind of worried like when I discovered
when she was banging around this morning
and I saw that she was like killing a
roach and I was like please don't bring
me that she probably wants to but yeah
all right we're gonna wrap it up so
again thank you very much everybody that
came and watched it we will probably do
another live stream tomorrow probably
about two o'clock Eastern Time so we'll
see you guys again tomorrow bye
that was a great show